Und du bist ein Interesse. Und du bist ein Interesse. Und du bist ein Interesse. Und du bist ein Interesse. Und du bist ein Interesse.
So, und damit sollte klar sein, wo ihr gelandet seid. Hallo und guten Abend beim Chaosradio auf Fritz, wie immer jeden letzten Donnerstag im Monat haben Leute, die im Club sind, im Chaos Computer Club das Studio geentert und werden uns in den nächsten zwei Stunden genauer aufklären über Dinge, die in diesem seltsamen Internet passieren, über das immer alle reden. Mit dabei sind heute Maha, hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und jemand, der Herr Obach genannt wird, hallo und guten Abend. Möglicherweise auch schon aus alten Chaosradio-Folgen bekannt, könnt ihr gerne mal angucken, es gibt schon ganz viele auf Chaosradio.de. Heute geht es um ein recht aktuelles Thema, denn wenn ihr euch ein bisschen um Netzpolitik kümmert oder dafür interessiert, möglicherweise auch in den großen Medien gehört habt, sind heute auf EU-Ebenen dreimal über ein Handelsabkommen namens ACTA abgestimmt worden und es ist dreimal abgelehnt worden. Das ist schon komisch genug, dass da dreimal drüber abgestimmt wurde. Wir wollen heute noch mal genau klären, worum geht es da, was ist daran jetzt so besonders, was ist daran protestierenswürdig, denn das tun die Leute, die man so im allgemeinen Netzgemeinde nennt, sehr häufig und sehr vielseitig gegen ACTA. Und dann, was ist eigentlich das Problem, denn ACTA ist ein Handelsabkommen, das wie so viele dieser Sachen sich darum dreht, dass Leute die Idee haben, okay, in dem komischen Internet, ihr ladet da einmal alle kostenlos Musik runter, das ist ungeil, wir müssen das jetzt mal irgendwie eindämmen. Und da ist ACTA so eine Methode, wo Leute denken, hey, das könnte doch ganz gut sein gegen diese ganzen Urheberrechtsverletzungen. Und diese Diskussion ist natürlich viel größer, denn außer das Internet einzuschränken, könnte man ja vielleicht denken so, ja, okay, die Sau ist jetzt irgendwie aus dem Sack, wir müssen uns vielleicht mal was Neues ausdenken, wie man im Internet irgendwie die Musik kopieren kann und dann vielleicht trotzdem, dass die Leute irgendwie zu Geld kommen, weil wir finden es ja geil, wenn sie gute Musik machen, die wir im Internet kopieren. Da gibt es dann also Vorschläge, wie man das Ganze klären könnte. Und über beide Seiten dieser Medaille wollen wir heute reden. Also einerseits dieses, okay, da gibt es Leute, die wollen das Internet irgendwie regulieren, ist das cool, und wenn ja, warum nicht, was macht man dagegen? Und die andere Seite so, wenn wir es nicht regulieren, das Internet bleibt so, wie es ist, und alle kopieren, wie sorgen wir dafür, dass Leute, die Kunst machen, trotzdem Geld kriegen? Das also sagen, der grobe Überblick über die nächsten drei Stunden. So, die Herren, was ich als allererstes von euch wissen würde, ist tatsächlich genau. Könnt ihr mal jeder in drei Sätzen erklären, was ACTA ist?
Ja, Herr Urbach, fang ich an. Ich danke dir, Maha, ja, in drei Sätzen. ACTA ist ein Handelsabkommen, das eigentlich Produktpiraterie eindämmen sollte, das dann aber auch recht schnell auf geistiges Eigentum, wie es so schon heißt, eingedämmt worden ist und das durchaus mehr als ein Problem mitgebracht hat. Das waren drei Sätze, jetzt bist du wieder dran. Ja, also Handelsabkommen wurde schon gesagt. Es geht eben um Produktpiraterie vordergründig, aber es gibt einen fünften Abschnitt, wo es dann plötzlich um das Internet geht. Und da soll jetzt plötzlich sogenanntes geistiges Eigentum, ich halte das ja immer noch für Neusprech, das soll eben im Internet gefestigt werden. Und das ist eben genau einer der vielen Problempunkte. Es gibt aber auch in den anderen Abschnitten Problempunkte. Die sind jetzt aber vielleicht heute nicht Thema.
Okay, die sagen, da kann man dann nochmal irgendwie drei Chaosradios draus machen wahrscheinlich. Was ist denn genau das Problem an ACTA? Also was wird denn da gefordert, was so schlimm ist? Oder was euch auf die Palme bringt?
Also erst mal, was wurde gefordert? Wir hatten das ja schon mal in Blue Moon auch besprochen gehabt, das Thema. ACTA hat ja sehr viel verschiedene Stufen durchgemacht, bis jetzt dann dieser Entwurf da ist, der jetzt auch abgestimmt worden ist, in den ersten Instanzen. Und es standen halt ganz klar Forderungen nach Three Strikes drin, wie wir es in Frankreich kennen. Also dreimal was untergeladen, dabei erwischt worden, Netz ist weg. Es standen drin die sogenannten Statutory Damages, das kennen wir aus den Staaten. Ich lade was runter und dann werde ich dabei erwischt und dann wird der entgangene Schaden, also der entgangene Gewinn eingeklagt, wo dann so 10, 4 Millionen Dollar für drei Songs dergleichen rauskommen. Das stand auch drin. Und die große Empörungswelle kam eigentlich, nachdem es alles schon wieder draußen war aus dem Vertrag, aber dann die alten Texte gefunden worden sind im Netz. Naja, also das war ja dieser Punkt der Geheimverhandlung. Also es wurde zunächst geheim verhandelt und das hat natürlich viele gestört. Aber jetzt auch das Ergebnis ist auch immer noch problematischer. Zu sagen, jetzt ist das ja alles entschärft und alles wunderbar, das ist natürlich nicht der Fall. Denn erstmal wird mit ACTA tatsächlich so ein, ja eigentlich, das angelsächsische Prinzip von Copyright hier eben auch versucht durchzusetzen. Wir haben ja ein bisschen anderen Ansatz in Europa mit dem Urheberrecht. Und es soll eben auch, es geht eben auch vor allen Dingen um solche Sachen wie Firesharing. Das wird als immer kommerziell angesehen. Und das ist natürlich ein Problem. Wir wollen ja vielleicht ein bisschen darauf hinarbeiten, dass Firesharing nicht nur was Kommerzielles ist, sondern eben, dass es auch den Aspekt der Privatkopie gibt. Und dieser Aspekt der Privatkopie, der ist eigentlich bei ACTA so nicht drin. Da wird also wirklich davon ausgegangen, dass jede Form von Firesharing kommerziell ist und deshalb eben auch verfolgt werden soll. Und vor allen Dingen werden auch die Provider mit dort in die Verantwortung genommen, gegen Firesharing vorzugehen. Und das wollen wir natürlich auch nicht, denn wir wollen ja natürlich Netzneutralität.
Okay, aber an dem Punkt würde ich gerne noch mal genauer nachhacken wollen. Wir kommen gleich noch mal ausführlicher zu dieser Geheimgehaltungsgeschichte. Also, dass es da ein großes Ding gibt, ein großes Handelsabkommen, das uns alle irgendwie beeinflusst, das aber von dem viele Leute gar nichts wussten. Was ist denn jetzt, so Provider sollen das Internet kontrollieren, was genau passiert da?
Das kann ich glaube ich ganz gut erklären. In ACTA stehen Formulierungen drin, die im Endeffekt sagen, dass die Provider mit der Privatwirtschaft, also z.B. mit Verwertern, wie einem Musiklabel oder einem Filmstudio Verträge abschließen sollen, dass sie sich darum kümmern, dass ihre Kunden keine Urheberrechtsverletzung mehr vollziehen. Das heißt, wir privatisieren Ermittlungsarbeit und privatisieren auch im Endeffekt Rechtsprechung, weil auch die Sanktionen dann zwischen denen vertraglich vereinbart werden und dann ich als Kunde, das in den AGBs mit unterschreibe, dass ich das halt nicht mehr mache, sonst passieren halt folgende Dinge. Und das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz großes Problem. Also Jeremy Zermanantisma, The Private Sector, Policing the Internet.
Also da ist der eine Vorwurf, eigentlich ist es Aufgabe von Polizei und Gerichten. Also es gibt glaube ich einen schönen aus dem Staatsberufgrunderricht Judikative, da irgendwie und Legislative danach zu forschen und das auch zu machen.
Die Exekutive ist jetzt gemeint.
Ach man, ey.
Also die Exekutive ist halt die Polizei, die Judikative, die Gerichte, die sollen tätig werden und nicht irgendein Privatmensch.
Siehst du, ich habe diesen Fehler jetzt nur gemacht, damit du es noch mal genau erklären kannst. Aber es schwingt ja auch, wenn man diese Kritik sich anguckt, immer noch so der Vorwurf der Überwachung und der Netzneutralität oder sowas man ja gerade schon sagte mit rein. Was hat das mit den Providern zu tun?
Naja, die Provider sollen halt jedes Paket durchgehen lassen. Die sollen sich nicht jedes Paket angucken und sagen, oh ja, das könnte eine Urheberrechtsverletzung sein, das soll jetzt mal nicht, das könnte irgendwie was anderes Illegales sein, das soll jetzt mal nicht, sondern ich meine, es gibt eben dieses Konzept der Privatheit und eigentlich sollen die Provider eben nur die Pakete weiter befördern und nicht da reingucken.
Das heißt, wenn die Provider das umsetzen würden, was bei ACTA geplant ist, müssten sie dann kompletten Traffic im Internet ankommen?
Genau, dann haben wir die totale Überwachung im Internet. Ach nee, das war nichts Gutes.
Jetzt ist heute gleich dreimal über ACTA abgestimmt worden. Wie kommt das? Ich dachte, wir haben nur ein Europaparlament.
Nee, nee, wir haben verschiedene Ausschüsse. Und es ist natürlich zunächst mal, das sagte ich vorhin schon, es geht ja immer darum, da wird ja alles als kommerziell betrachtet. Also auch eben das Freistellung und das ist halt ein Handelsabkommen. Das heißt, der Industrieausschuss ist zuständig, weil man irgendwie denkt, es geht um Handel und Industrie und so. Früher war das mal der Fischereiausschuss sogar. Naja, jedenfalls, die haben als Erste abgestimmt und es gab also eine knappe Mehrheit gegen ACTA. Dann anschließend der Rechtsausschuss, das wird ja hier am Rechts fragen. Also so ein Handelsabkommen hat ja den Status im Grunde eines Gesetzes. Es ist zwar kein Gesetz, ein Handelsabkommen, aber wenn der Staat das ratifiziert oder die EU das ratifiziert, dann hat das Gesetzeskraft. Deshalb muss der Rechtsausschuss sich damit beschäftigen. Und, und das ist jetzt genau ja unser Punkt, da sind ja massiv Bürgerrechte betroffen. Nämlich eben tatsächlich Netzneutralität. Das ist natürlich ein Bürgerrecht. Es ist klar, dass wir uns frei informieren müssen. Inletzt deshalb eben auch der Ausschuss für Bürgerrechte.
Wieso haben die sozusagen votiert? Alle dagegen, also knapp, aber halt doch dagegen. Was ist das jetzt? Also heißt das jetzt jetzt vom Tisch oder?
Nee, leider nicht. Die Ausschüsse bereiten ja immer nur die Sitzung des Parlaments vor, das Plenum, und das Plenum muss halt abstimmen. Und jetzt haben wir das Problem, das war schon alles sehr, sehr knapp. Wir haben ja auch leider noch sehen müssen, dass eben auch die Gruppe der Liberalen umgefallen ist und dafür gestimmt hat. Und jetzt besteht natürlich die Gefahr, wo das so knapp ist, dass im Parlament die Mehrheit nicht dagegen ist, weil jetzt natürlich hinter den Kulissen verhandelt wird. Die Lobbyisten sind natürlich dann wieder vorne, also verschiedene Lobbyisten, aber eben vor allen Dingen Leute, die auch für Urheberrecht sich einsetzen und für Leistungsschutzrechte und so. Das ist natürlich eine starke Gruppe. Die werden natürlich jetzt nochmal den Druck erhöhen, um dann eben zu gucken, was im Parlament passiert. Und da besteht die Gefahr, dass dann doch ACTA dort im Parlament Zustimmung findet. Man darf auch nicht vergessen, wie stark diese Lobbygruppen sind. Also gerade im Filmbereich die MPA, die Motion Picture Association. Das ist eine Gründung der MPAA, der Motion Picture Association of America, die nur Lobbyarbeit für amerikanische Filmstudios in Europa machen.
Das wollte ich jetzt auch gerade fragen. Also was gibt denn da so an Mitspielern?
Das ist so eine Lobby, die auch sehr kräftig dahinter her ist. Es gibt natürlich noch viele andere, also die Musikindustrie erstmal. Die sind ja auch wohl die Hauptleidtragenden. Es gibt ja diese schöne, das müssen wir dann irgendwie auch noch verlinken, Alva Freude, der ja auch in der Enquete-Kommission ist, hat ja die Zahlen mal angeschaut, die bei der Enquete-Kommission rausgekommen sind. Da sieht man, dass der Gewinn der Filmindustrie laufend steigt, trotz des Internets. Die einzigen Leidtragenden sind irgendwie die Musikindustrie, und deshalb sind die auch besonders aktiv jetzt. Da gibt es ja einmal die Musikunternehmen, Verleger selbst, aber natürlich auch Verwertungsgesellschaften, wie zum Beispiel die GEMA in Deutschland, sowas gibt es ja auch in anderen Ländern, die natürlich da auch ganz stark Druck machen und natürlich immer damit kommen, unsere Mitglieder verdienen immer weniger und wir müssen uns wehren und wir kriegen kaum Geld von Google und das können wir unseren Mitgliedern nicht verkaufen, die wollen Geld verdienen. Ja, und da wird man ein bisschen auf die Trenendriese gedrückt und dann fällt natürlich der ein oder andere Politiker um, wie wir jetzt ja gerade gesehen haben.
Jetzt gibt es sozusagen viele Lobbyisten von Seiten der Urheberrechtsindustrie.
Eine Gruppe haben wir noch vergessen, die Zeitungsverleger. Es ist besonders um Murdoch, dem weltweit wichtigsten Zeitungsverleger herum, gibt es ganz stark einen Lobbydruck. Der macht sich sehr stark, der hat ja auch hier in Deutschland, haben ja auch die mit Murdoch verbundenen Presseerzeugnisse auch sich sehr stark für das Leistungsschutzrecht stark gemacht. Und das ist natürlich auch wieder eine wichtige Gruppe, die da ist.
Müssen wir vielleicht nochmal kurz erklären, Leistungsschutzrecht, gerade im Begriff Zeitung, da geht es darum, dass manche Leute der Ansicht sind, dass man immer ein kleiner Austritt von Text irgendwo im Internet irgendwie weiterverbreitet wird, soll dafür auch Geld bezahlt werden. Ein Beispiel ist, ihr schreibt was in euer Blog. Ein anderes Beispiel ist, irgendwelche Suchmaschinen oder Zeitungszusammenfassungsdienste bringen, vollautomatisiert, Zitat auf ihrer Seite. Da wird also viel diskutiert. Es gibt viele Lobbyisten, also für diese Industrie.
Aber meine Lieblingsgruppe möchte ich noch erwähnen.
Haben wir immer noch nicht alle.
Also meine Lieblingsgruppe ist...
Also ich sag nur halb sind Nachrichten, bis dahin müssen wir sie auch wieder erklären.
Nein, die gibt es nur viele. Das klingt zu abstrus, meine Lieblingslobbygruppe ist die der spanischsprachigen Seifenopernproduzenten.
Okay, ist das ein großes...
Das ist ein großes Ding in Mexiko. Das ist irgendwie eine Haupteinnahmequelle Mexikos. Das sind Seifenopern, die sie ins Ausland exportieren. Und da die einfach nachgedreht werden, und statt dass jemand die Lizenz kauft und das dann nachgedreht, werden die einfach nachgedreht. Oder nicht einfach synchronisiert und ausgestrahlt, sondern sie werden halt wie gesagt nachgedreht. Und das ist ein großes Problem für die Mexikaner.
Hier in Europa?
Auch hier in Europa gibt es spanischsprachige Menschen und auch die schauen Seifenopern.
Aus Mexiko nachgedreht. Also die mexikanischen Produzenten sind aktiv in den ACTA-Prozess hier in Europa verwickelt?
Nach aktiv Lobbyarbeit.
Was ich jetzt noch wissen wollte ist, das ist ja alles eine Seite. Jetzt seid ihr zwei Leute von der Seite, die ACTA nicht so derbe geil finden, um es diplomatisch zu formulieren. Gibt es auch da Lobbyarbeiter?
Na ja, klar. Man sieht es ja. Wir haben jetzt schon Alva Freude erwähnt. Es gibt natürlich eine ganze Reihe von Leuten, die da auch versuchen, das entsprechend klarzukriegen. Netzpolitik ist da mit dabei. DigiGas, der Chaos Computer Club, der sitzt ja auch hier. Wir sind natürlich alle dabei, immer wieder darauf hinzuweisen, dass hier ein Problem besteht und dass man ACTA so ohne Weiteres nicht durchgehen lassen kann. Wir haben natürlich auch noch den Vorteil, dass wir eben auch noch sozusagen die Bürger hinter uns haben. Es gibt eben die Möglichkeit, Demos zu machen.
Was ich kurz fragen wollte ist, wenn ihr jetzt von den Lobbyisten sprecht, der Verwertungsindustrie, da stelle ich mir natürlich den klassischen Anzugmann mit dem Geldkoffer vor. Das wird nicht ganz so krass funktionieren, aber der ist vor allen Dingen in Brüssel. Ihr seid hier. Gibt es auch in Brüssel Leute, die die Lobbyarbeit für euch machen?
Ja, da gibt es z.B. Jeremy Zimmermann von La Quartier du Net. Wer das nicht kennt, LQDN, das ist eine französische Organisation, die sich auch frei das Netz verschrieben hat. Das sind eigentlich alles ehemalige Anwälte oder sind teilweise auch Praktizierende. Und die machen seit Jahren Lobbyarbeit für ein freies Netz, vor allem in Brüssel. Das ist aber auch z.B. Idri, die European Digital Rights, habe ich vergessen, das letzte ist um Joe McNamee, die auch da Lobbyarbeit machen. Auch sehr gute, viele Broschüren, die momentan im Parlament verteilt werden, also gegen ACTA, sind von Idri geschrieben worden. Also auch die von der DigiGuess ist eigentlich die Idri-Broschürin und Deutsche übersetzt. Solche Dinge, also es gibt schon welche, aber es sind natürlich viel zu wenige. Es sind ein paar wenige Akteure, die da, also von unserer Seite sind es zu wenige. Es gibt aber noch mehr, ich meine, wir haben auch noch Verbündete, also die Internetprovider zum Beispiel. Die sind natürlich auch auf unserer Seite, weil die natürlich auch keine Lust haben, die Hilfsscherefs zu spielen und da irgendwie für irgendwelche Urheber da Geld einzusammeln. Und von daher sind die auch natürlich auf unserer Seite und sagen, wir müssen an der Netznotarität festhalten.
Okay, also es gibt sozusagen zwei Seiten und es ist nicht, also es ist ein bisschen ungleichgewichtig, aber nicht so ganz doll schlimm. Es gibt also Chancen. Jetzt war eine der Sachen, die gleich am Anfang auch vorkamen, dass das geheim gehalten wurde. Die Verhandlungen zu ACTA sind hinter verschlossenen Türen quasi passiert. Ab und zu ist da was rausgekommen, man wusste es dann nicht so genau. Da gab es aber doch wieder Gerüchte und so. Und einen wichtigen Beitrag dazu hat jemand geleistet, der jetzt am Telefon ist und zwar Matthias. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hi, guten Abend.
Du hast sozusagen, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, unter anderem mit dafür gesorgt, dass wir Einblick in die Dinge haben, die rund um ACTA passiert sind. Was genau war da deine Rolle?
Du sprichst so ein bisschen aus der Zukunft, wir sind gerade noch dabei. Ich habe einen Tag nachdem die großen Demos in Deutschland, in Europa stattgefunden haben, ein Dokument auf den Tisch bekommen, das die Europäische Kommission geschrieben hatte, indem sie belegen wollten, wie transparent sie während der Verhandlungen waren. Und da war unter anderem auch eine Auflistung, welche EU-Mitgliedsstaaten an den Verhandlungsrunden zu ACTA teilgenommen haben. Allerdings war diese Aufzählung immer nur so Frankreich, Deutschland etc. und niemals ein Name oder ein Ministerium oder irgendwie weitergehende Informationen. Und mit dieser einzelnen Auflistung bin ich dann zum Bundeskanzleramt, zum Auswärtigen Amt und zum Bundesjustizministerium gegangen und habe eine Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfrage gestellt, jeweils wer von euch hat an diesen Verhandlungsrunden teilgenommen und was habt ihr sonst noch an Informationen zu ACTA.
Und die Antwort darauf war?
Die Antwort war, dass diese Frage keine einfache Frage im Sinne des Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes ist und die Beantwortung bis zu 500 Euro kosten kann. Das hat dann erstmal für gesagt, dass ich die letzte Frage, nämlich gibt mir alles was ihr zu ACTA habt, zurückgestellt habe und mich erstmal nur konzentriert habe auf diesen Punkt. Wer hat daran teilgenommen? Und ein paar Wochen später kam dann vom Justizministerium ein Antwortschreiben, in dem sie letztendlich diese Beantwortung abgelehnt haben mit einer selten kreativen Begründung, nämlich durch die Bekanntgabe der Namen der angestellten Beamten im Ministerium, die an diesen Runden teilgenommen haben, würde die öffentliche Sicherheit gefährdet werden. Das ist nämlich eine der Ausschussgründe für die Herausgabe von Informationen nach dem IFG.
Okay, also ich möchte das noch mal kurz zusammenfassen. Du hast also angefragt, wer von der Bundesrepublik Deutschland an einem Handelsabkommen teilgenommen hat, wo es darum ging, wie unser Internet in Zukunft funktionieren wird. Und da hat die Bundesregierung quasi gesagt, das sagen wir dir nicht, weil es ist gefährlich.
Das ist einfach nur gefährlich, also die öffentliche Sicherheit ist das.
Und Ordnung.
Das ist also noch mal extra gefährlich. Und wie ist denn jetzt das weitere Vorgehen?
Diese Antwort, genauso wie die Frage, habe ich veröffentlicht auf Frag den Staat. Das ist ein Portal, um für Bürger bequemer Informationsfreiheitsanfragen zu stellen. Und Markus Becketer von Netzpolitik hat diese Antwort vom Ministerium gelesen, hat vermutlich auch gelacht und hat dann einen Spendenaufruf gespartet über netzpolitik.org und gesagt, wie wäre es denn, wenn die Netzgemeinde den Widerspruch gegen diesen Bescheid, eine mögliche Klage auf den Verwaltungsweg, sowie weitere Anfragen nach dem IFG und Informationsarbeit zum Thema ACTA finanzieren würde, in dieser reinen Folge. Und das war über ein Wochenende, so Freitagabend glaube ich, kam dieser Spendenaufruf. Und in den nächsten 48 Stunden gingen, glaube ich, 7000 Euro an Spenden rein. Damit sind jetzt erst mal die 30 Euro abgedeckt, die das Widerschussverfahren kosten würde. Wenn es ebenfalls abgelehnt wird. Und auch die Anwaltskosten der Rechtsanwaltskanzlei, die jetzt mit der Formulierung des Widerspruchs beauftragt worden ist. Und wenn jetzt eine Antwort kommt, dann ist sie entweder positiv oder sie ist negativ. Und wenn sie negativ ist, dann heißt dann die nächste Station Verwaltungsbericht.
Ja, sehr schön. Das endet alles immer irgendwie wieder vor Gerichten und die Netzgemeinde muss es dann finanzieren. Das ist ja nicht zum ersten Mal, dass sowas passiert.
Darf ich, Matthias, auch noch eine Frage stellen? Ja, und zwar, du hattest doch auch was gesagt über die verschiedenen, also wo wir es das letzte Mal gehalten haben, über die verschiedenen Versionen von ACTA. Also das interessiert mich natürlich als Sprachwissenschaftler. Kannst du da kurz noch was zu sagen zu den verschiedenen Sprachversionen, den verschiedenen Konzepten, die da mit dahinterstehen?
Wie nicht. Also es gibt ja unter anderem durch Michael Geist, einen kanadischen Rechtsprofessor, und durch andere interessierte Gruppen sehr frühe Veröffentlichungen des ACTA-Entwurfs. Und man kann natürlich so ähnlich wie in einem Wiki jetzt die einzelne Version übereinanderlegen und schauen, an welchen Stellen, gab es noch Dissens, der ist teilweise bei einigen Leaks noch ausgestrichen gewesen, und an welchen Stellen hat man eine Konkretisierung geschaffen. Nach allen Informationen, die ich habe, gab es eigentlich nirgendwo eine Konkretisierung, sondern immer nur eine Aufweichung und auch bis hin zur Entwicklung neuer undefinierter Begriffe, die dann erst im Laufe, nach der Ratifizierung erst mit Leben gefüllt werden müssen. Ich glaube, am besten herausgearbeitet, auch gerade im Bezug auf die Auswirkungen auf das Internet, hat tatsächlich die Gesellschaft diese Punkte und halt auch die Gefahren darauf hingewiesen, wo tatsächlich Begriffe, die es vorher nicht gab, dazu führen werden, dass wir von rechtsstaatlichen Standards, die wir heute haben, abkommen werden.
Matthias Schindler, vielen Dank für diesen ersten Einblick darin, wie schwierig es sein kann, Einblicke in Verhandlungen zu bekommen, die uns eigentlich alle eingehen, alle angehen, so rum. Und einen schönen Abend ja noch.
Danke, gleichfalls.
So, jetzt haben wir sozusagen den groben, kleinen Anfang gemacht, was ACTA angeht. Wir können uns vielleicht gleich noch ein bisschen genauer damit beschäftigen, was da die Gefahren sind. Vorher gibt's aber hier das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Heute Chaosradio hier im Blumen. Zu Gast sind Herr Obach und Maha. Hallo, guten Abend, willkommen zurück. Und es geht um ACTA, um den Kopierkulturkampf und um möglicherweise Alternativen, wie wir Künstler im Netz irgendwie Geld zukommen lassen können, obwohl wir einfach so ihre Musik kopieren. Am Anfang beschäftigen wir uns aber mit ACTA. ACTA haben wir gelernt, ist ein Handelsabkommen, das dazu dienen soll, das Internet mehr oder weniger auch zu überwachen, damit da nicht mehr kopiert werden kann. Da sind Leute aus verschiedenen Gründen dagegen und das würde ich gleich gerne noch mal ein bisschen genauer wissen. Wie immer gilt im Blue Moon und auch im Chaosradio, wenn ihr eine Frage habt oder eure Meinung dazu sagen wollt, könnt ihr gerne anrufen. Die Telefonnummer dazu ist 0331 70 97 110. Und der erste Anrufer, den wir heute haben, kommt von ganz weit her aus den Niederlanden, nämlich Dauhe Schmidt. Hallo und guten Abend. Wie bist du denn hierher gekommen?
Wie ich im Radio hierher gekommen bin oder ACTA?
Erstmal zum Radio. Anrufe aus den Niederlanden haben wir ja nicht so häufig.
Oh ja, ich höre das gerne immer jedes Monat an eigentlich.
Sehr schön.
Ich muss mir auch direkt entschuldigen vor meinem Deutsch, weil ich kann mir den ganzhaus mit dem Genitiv und Dativ und so, aber ich versuch's herzukriegen, um zu erklären.
Maa hat ja Hobby als Sprache. Wenn es ganz schlimm wird, wird er dich korrigieren. Aber ich kann das auch nicht richtig. Wie bist du denn zu ACTA gekommen?
Ich arbeite bei einem Hosting-Provider hier in Amsterdam, Greenhost, und wir sind ziemlich beschäftigt eigentlich mit Journalisten. Wir helfen Journalisten, die nach Ausland gehen, um Daten zu schützen, so mit Encryption oder solchen Sachen. Und dann hat eine uns da aufgewiesen, ACTA ist so ein Ding am Moment, und die meisten sehen das im Bereich, dass wir im Westen oder so nicht länger die Möglichkeit haben, um unsere Daten zu unterladen, Firmen anzugucken oder MP3s auszutauschen. Aber der Journalist hat uns da aufgewiesen, das geht noch viel weiter. Das ACTA wird auch möglicherweise als Vorbild für andere Länder benutzt. Und möglicherweise auch als Unterdruckungsapparat.
Du meinst, dass die Dinge, die bei ACTA implementiert werden sollen, also die Überwachungsinfrastruktur der Providern, gleich noch für andere Sachen mitgenutzt wird?
Genau, genau, so hier vor uns wird es darum gehen, dass wenn ein Person, ein Journalist oder so, der macht ein Blogartikel, der benutzt dabei ein schönes Bild, ein Foto oder so, aber der hat nicht den Rechten vor dem Bild bekommen. Das Blogartikel wird hauptsächlich populärer sind und viele Leute gucken sich das an. Dann sind wir als Provider auch verantwortlich dafür. Das ist hier in der Niederlande oder in Deutschland schon schlimm, aber in vielen anderen Ländern wird das möglicherweise auch benützbar sein als Unterdruckungsmechanismus, ein richtiger Sensorenmechanismus.
Dass man also nicht nur sagt, hier das muss raus, weil der gehört aus Urheberrecht gar nicht, sondern das als Vorwand nutzt und sagt, die Information passt uns gerade nicht so schön in unsere Diktatur. Und damit wollt ihr als Hoster quasi gar nichts zu tun haben?
Ja genau, sowieso denken wir uns, dass die Arbeit wird uns fast so unmöglich gemacht werden. Und wenn es ACTA geben würde, ich glaube nicht, dass ACTA noch geben würde, dann müssen wir eigentlich fast alle Dateien, die unseren Kunden bei uns auf dem Surfen speichern, müssen wir alle kontrollieren. Das wird so ähnlich wie, ich habe ein Hotel oder so und die Leute kommen rein und bieten sich ein Zimmer. Und ich muss dann eigentlich in jeder Zimmer muss ich Überwachungskameras aufhängen, weil ich musste aufpassen, dass die da nichts tun, was nicht erlaubt ist. Das kann man sich vorstellen, ich würde binnen zwei Monaten kein Business mehr haben.
Das würde dann wahrscheinlich sehr teuer werden. Wie ist denn der Protest bei euch jetzt konkret ausgeprägt? Also macht ihr da als Host da bei Demos mit oder wie macht ihr das?
Na ja, es gibt eine Leitung, dass ich natürlich nach Chaosradio anhöre, weil hier in der Niederlande ist das ein bisschen alles so schwächer, würde ich sagen. So, es gibt schon Protesten, wie vorher schon gesagt, es gibt E3 und andere Clubs auf europäischem Niveau. Wir haben Betto Freedom in der Niederlande und die machen sehr tolle und gute Arbeit. Die setzen sich richtig gut vor ein. Wir haben ein paar richtig kritische Politiker im Europarlament. Aber ich muss sagen, so bei Jan-Normalverbraucher, wie man das sagt, ist das kein Thema auf diesem Moment.
Da könnt ihr vielleicht hier die anwesenden Experten dem Dauer noch irgendwie Tipps geben. Das ist ja bei vielen dieser Netzpolitik-Themen ein großes Problem. Wie vermittelt man das an die Leute, die damit nichts zu tun haben, die damit nichts zu tun haben wollen, die damit vielleicht auch zu einem Teil nichts zu tun haben müssen, aber sich vielleicht dann doch interessieren müssen in dem Hinsicht, dass es vielleicht wichtig für ihr Leben ist? Also wie vermittelt man das, dass man es versteht, aber nicht dann irgendwie selber gleich alles lernen muss?
Also ich denke, man kann sich ein bisschen mit den Journalisten verbünden. Denn die haben ja ein ganz vitales Interesse daran, dass sie halt auch recherchieren können und ihre Informanten nicht preisgeben müssen. Und wenn da alles überwacht ist, dann ist das immer ganz schlecht. Also die verstehen immer sehr schnell, dass Überwachung nicht gut ist. Und ich denke, da sollte man auf jeden Fall dran arbeiten. Deshalb immer Journalisten, Provider und überhaupt demonstrieren. Also die Bevölkerung.
Na ja, in der Niederlande ist das auch ein bisschen krass auf dem Moment, würde ich sagen. Es gibt so einen richtigen Streit zwischen Parlament und die Richter. Weil wir sind glaube ich auch eine der ersten Länder, wo der Paralympic zum Beispiel richtig blockiert werden ist.
Genau, da müssen doch die Leute jetzt endlich mal wach werden.
Das sind die auch. Aber da gab es ein bisschen so Aufstand. Das passiert noch meistens auf Netz. Da gab es auch ein paar Demos, aber nicht so wirklich. Aber man muss auch sagen, auf die andere Seite sind wir auch in Chile, das zweite Land der Welt, wo es Netzneutralität gibt. So festgelegt im Gesetz. Und ich denke auch, wie es jetzt abläuft mit ACTA, wie es vorher abgelaufen ist mit PIPA, nicht SOPA meine ich, und jetzt mit Netznetze, ja die Abkost-Singeln. Ich glaube, die meisten sind auch ziemlich positiv, dass es in die gute Richtung geht sozusagen, dass das Netz von den Politikern auch beschützt wird.
Okay, also die Stimmung ist eigentlich ganz gut, man müsste nur noch ein bisschen mehr Leute mobilisieren.
Ja, so mehr auf internationalen Niveau, würde ich sagen. So wie ACTA geht natürlich weiter, über Grenzen. Aber das ist vielleicht zu abstrakt für die meisten auch.
Daulf, vielen Dank für den Einblick ins Nachbarland. Und viel Glück noch und am 9. Juni, nächsten Samstag, ist Großartigstagsstag.
Am 9. Juni gehen wir alle auf die Straße.
Alles klar, dann viel Spaß dabei. Bis dann, tschüss, danke. So, dann können wir das gleich mal vorziehen. Wir sagen es nachher bestimmt ausführlich, aber 9. Juni ist ein weltweiter, europaweiter, was auch immer. Erzähl mal genau, Aktionstag.
Ja, also in allen größeren Städten findet was statt. Hier in Berlin wird es um 12 Uhr an der Oberbaumbrücke losgehen. Und in anderen Städten, da muss man sich jetzt informieren, da müssten wir nochmal einen Link posten.
Wir haben einen Blog zur Sendung, Chaosradio.de.
Wir haben einen Chat zur Sendung auf Renote, ERC-Chat, wer das noch kennt. Es gibt ein Pad zur Sendung. Wer das schon kennt. Wer das schon kennt. Also wie gesagt, es gibt verschiedene Kommunikationsmittel. Und da müssen wir das dann nochmal einstellen. Also wie gesagt, in allen großen Städten, und zwar nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern weltweit. Also am 9. Juni, also übernächsten Samstag, da wird es dann richtig losgehen. Und ich denke, da sollten auch wirklich alle kommen, weil es wirklich ganz wichtig ist.
Das wird also der Aktionstag. Jetzt hat Dower aus Niedern ja gerade gesagt, für die würde sich tatsächlich was ändern. Ich habe jetzt, ich weiß gar nicht, wann es war, Anfang letzten Jahres, als die Diskussion um ACTA schon so richtig schlimm war, mal mit einem Rechtsanwalt gesprochen. Der Herr Stadler war es, glaube ich, der auch bloggt. Und der meinte, das Krasse an ACTA ist für Deutschland eigentlich, dass was auch immer da jetzt drin steht, also der aktuelle Stand, den wir auch kennen, ist für uns, würde sich gar nichts ändern. Das gilt sowieso schon alles.
Das ist auch wieder so ein Nebel, der ausgeschüttet wurde und sogar vernünftige Leute wie Herrn Stadler erfasst hat. Aber sag du mal was dazu. Ja, also wie gesagt, was wir schon ansprachen, dass private Unternehmen anfangen, das Netz zu überwachen, auf Grundlage von Verträgen. Das ist eine krasse Änderung. Das ist so momentan, glaube ich, nicht möglich. Dann auch, das halt sehr spannend ist.
Um noch mal kurz dabei zu bleiben, diese Sache steht doch in einem aktuellen Entwurf, den wir kennen, muss man mal zugehören, nicht mehr drin, oder?
Doch, es steht noch drin, dass sämtliches File Sharing zu behandeln ist als kommerziell. Also die Idee der Privatkopie ist da nicht drin. Das hat vorhin auch jemand hier im Pad gefragt, was ist eigentlich eine Privatkopie?
Da brauchen wir es vielleicht machen. Da will ich tatsächlich später zu kommen, aber steht da noch explizit drin, dass die Provider den Dingens überwachen sollen?
Und zwar über den kommerziellen Bereich. Und was ja sehr spannend ist, ist, dass...
Ach so, warte. Ich spring gerade. Also da steht drin, die Provider sollen für den kommerziellen Bereich, den Internetverkörper, wachen. Und dann wird an anderer Stelle definiert, jede Kopie ist kommerziell.
Genau.
Okay, da ist der Zusammenhang.
Meine Lieblingsstelle ist immer noch, wo es um das Fair Trial geht im Vertrag. Da wird gesagt, dass es einen Fair Trial geben muss, in diesem Prozess der Überwachung, der Bestrafung und auch die Überwachung. Und der Begriff Fair Trial ist bei uns, also ein faires Verfahren, ist bei uns eine völlig andere Bedeutung als Fair Trial in den Staaten. Aber darüber wird nicht gesprochen, was es denn ist. Es wird nicht definiert.
Wie das steht da jetzt drin?
Da steht der Begriff Fair Trial drin.
Okay, was ist das denn in den Staaten?
Also bei uns ist es ein Faires Verfahren. Kennen wir ja so vom Gericht mit Anwälten und allem Pipapo. Ein Fair Trial ist einfach nur, dass es ein gerechter Prozess ist. Also Prozess im Sinne von Prozesskette.
Ja, also Ding was passiert. Also nicht Gerichtsprozess, sondern einfach ein Prozess. Also da passiert eine Handlung.
Genau, da passieren halt Dinge.
Und welche Bedeutung hat die, die im ACTA drin steht?
Das wissen wir nicht.
Ah, weiß das jemand?
Das weiß im Zweifel das ACTA-Büro, das gerade in Tokio aufgebaut wird oder dann aufgebaut werden soll. Denn die haben die Protokolle von den Sitzungen und das sind diejenigen, die die Auslegung im Zweifelsfall machen.
Ich erinnere mich dunkel, dass es zu diesem irgendwie, wie wissen wir überhaupt, was da drin steht? Also klar, wir haben schon mit Matthias Schindler gesprochen, der jetzt versucht hat sozusagen auf dem offiziellen Wege da ranzukommen, aber gab es nicht noch irgendwelche Geschichten mit Kopierten übermittelt?
Wo wir die, also der erste Leak war wunderschön. Das war, da hat einer von der japanischen Delegation hat den Entwurf abfotografiert und die Fotos gescannt. Und die haben wir dann auf Wikileaks gefunden.
Okay.
Das war der erste Entwurf. Dann haben wir die tätig abfotografiert und entwickeln lassen. Und dann wie ihr es kennt. Ansonsten sind halt immer wieder plötzlich irgendwo in obskuren Mailboxen, also E-Mail-Postfächern plötzlich PDFs aufgetaucht.
Und weiß man dann von wem die kamen?
Dazu kann ich nichts sagen.
Okay. Hat sich denn mittlerweile diese Sache eigentlich geändert? Oder ändert sich das zumindest, dass diese Verhandlungen jetzt mal öffentlich sind?
Es wird ja nicht mehr verhandelt. Das ist ja das Spannende.
Okay, also der Vertrag steht jetzt fest?
Der ist so fest. Den haben wir auch verlinkt im PAN. Genau. Und der ist auch offiziell veröffentlicht. Aber das ist jetzt halt diese Endversion. Wir wissen also nicht, wie er entstanden ist genau. Und alle Unklarheiten in dem Vertrag werden halt vom ACTA-Büro erläutert. Auf Grundlage der Protokolle der Verhandlungssitzung. Und die sind nach wie vor nicht zugänglich.
Okay, das muss ich nochmal vielleicht auch hier an dieser Stelle genau erklären. Es gibt also in diesem Vertrag, in diesem Papier, gibt es sozusagen unklare Worte. Wir hatten als Beispiel gerade Fair Trial.
Genau.
Und das hattet ihr auch gesagt, das hatte Matthias erzählt, in dem Verhandlungsverlauf ist der Vertrag eigentlich immer schwammiger geworden.
Genau, die klaren Formulierungen wurden immer weniger. Und ähm, wurde immer schwammiger. Auch Bedeutungsdinge, die ich sehr spannend finde, ist, in der englischen Version wird von Copyright gesprochen. In der deutschen von Urheberrecht. Das ist die Übersetzungsvariante davon.
Was klang vorhin schon mal an? Was ist denn da jetzt der Unterschied?
Ja, Copyright ist das, was wir aus UK und aus den Staaten kennen. Also ich erstelle ein Werk und melde es an. Und erhalte damit das Copyright auf das Werk. Also kann auch eine Firma ein Werk anmelden gehen. Wir kennen das Copyright bei 20th Century Fox. Das ist ein Studio. Das Copyright kann man verkaufen. Genau, man kann das Copyright handeln. Wenn ich in Deutschland ein Werk erstelle, habe ich immer das Urheberrecht. Ich kann nur meine Verwertungsrechte verkaufen. Aber wäre dann der Film Star Wars nicht Copyright bei Lucas Firm, sondern Copyright bei Schleffern Urbach als Beispiel.
Lass uns mal ein ganz fragliches Beispiel machen, weil das immer so gesagt wird und dann so verschwindet. Das Urheberrecht an dieser Show, die wir hier gerade produzieren, haben quasi Maha, Herr Urbach und Markus Richter. Das Verwertungsrecht hat Fritz vom RBB. Genau. In Amiland wäre es so, ich werde bezahlt, ihr seid Gäste.
Und dafür kompensiert auch irgendwie.
Genau. Und das hat dann also komplett, was damit passiert, ist alles in Händen des Senders dann. Und das ist im ACTA aber sozusagen, sind diese Unterschiede gar nicht geklärt worden?
Nee, das ist, wir haben, es gibt ein Abkommen. Also nicht wirklich, schon irgendwie. Also es gilt natürlich der englische Text. Der englische Text ist ausschlaggebend. Die deutsche Übersetzung ist halt nur so ein Abklatsch davon. Und da ist die Rede von Copyright. Das heißt, es geht in Wirklichkeit tatsächlich um Verwertungsrechte.
Aber ist denn das, da hat doch gerade schon wieder einer die Mail. Wessen Mail war das?
Ich war das nicht.
Ihr müsst nämlich wissen, jedes Mal, wenn hier ein elektronisches Gerät, wo fand es beim Chaosradio nicht nur eins gibt, ein Geräusch macht, schuldet derjenige ein Kasten-Erfrischungsgetränk.
Das war ich.
Zu Anfang war ich es, aber ich hätt's nicht. Ich hab eine E-Mail bekommen.
Wir sind jetzt schon bei drei Kästen. Es wird ein ordentliches Gelage am Ende dieser Sendung. Und ihr könnt auch gerne noch anrufen, 0331 70 97 110, wenn ihr Fragen habt. Jetzt haben wir am 9. Juni den großen Protesttag. Bis jetzt ging das alles über Lobbyarbeit. Ist es schon abzusehen? Wird das jetzt schiefgehen mit dem ACTA? Also wird es tatsächlich abgelehnt?
Also es ist wichtig, dass wirklich viele auf die Straße gehen. Wir müssen nochmal ähnliche Zeichen, dass wir bei der ersten großen ACTA-Demo, also es ist jetzt nicht okay zu Hause zu bleiben. Das ist nicht okay. Geht auf die Straße, zeigt, dass ihr da seid, dass ihr das nicht wollt. Denn wir müssen nochmal ganz klare Signale nach Brüssel senden. Und das geht nicht, wenn wir zu Hause bleiben.
Hilft das denn eigentlich wirklich was? Also das frage ich mich ja immer so sagen. Wir demonstrieren hier damit in Brüssel was anderes.
Nach der letzten großen ACTA-Demo, also dieser ersten großen, den wir alle kennen, in ganz Europa, hat Karel de Gacht, das ist der europäische Handelskommissar, einen verwirrten Brief geschrieben an die verschiedenen Abgeordneten, um zu erklären, warum die Proteste völlig falsch sind, dass es gar nicht so schlimm sei. Also er ist richtig in eine Notlage geraten, auch in einer Erklärungsnotlage. Und schrieb halt, dass diese Proteste gesteuert sind. Und sehr, sehr spannend.
Wer steht da angeblich dahinter?
Es war so rastrussig, ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Okay, kann man vielleicht auch einen Link in das...
Den Brief gibt's bei Lackwacht und die Jüdinett veröffentlicht. Einfach mal nach LQDN in Karategacht suchen. Da gibt's ein paar schöne Links. Und wenn ihr Informationen über den Aktionsdach haben wollt, dann nehmt ihr die Suchmaschine eurer Wahl, zum Beispiel www.dakta.go.com und gebt da einfach Aktionsdach gegen ACTA 9. Juni ein. Und ihr habt die Links eurer Geschmacksrichtung. Auf Englisch kann man es auch einrichten. Dann hat man sogar die internationalen Termine. Und auf Deutsch kann man sich dann sogar noch seine Partei aussuchen, die von der man Infos haben will.
Also sind alle Parteien dagegen?
Deutschland sieht so aus. Die Liberalen sind jetzt glaube ich nur auf europäischer Ebene umgefallen. In Deutschland aber glaube ich noch nicht. Das weiß ich nicht so genau. Und die anderen Parteien sind inzwischen alle gegen ACTA sogar. Aus dem C-Netz, also dieser Gruppe der CDU und CSU, hört man scharfe Töne gegen ACTA. Da ist nichts mehr zu wollen.
Also C-Netz muss man wissen, ist der Netzpolitik Teil der Union, aber kommt das sogar aus diesem Teil oder kommt das wirklich aus der ganzen Union?
Ja, ich glaube in der ganzen Union ist das noch nicht richtig ausgedängelt. Das ist nicht ausgeskutiert in der Union, aber das C-Netz, das zumindest da auch spannenderweise recht schnell Einfluss in die Union bekommen hat. Aufgrund dessen, dass viele MDBs da Mitglieder sind und Erika Schneibacher es mit gegründet hat, haben sie ein gewisses Gewicht in der Union. Aber auch Menschen, die vorher für ACTA waren, sind leider, klingen nicht mehr so danach.
Das hört sich ja jetzt alles an, als ob man sich im Großen und Ganzen möglicherweise schon mal mit den Gedanken anfreunden könnte, dass unter Umständen ACTA möglicherweise doch gar nicht unter Umständen eventuell stattfindet. Aber jetzt ist es ja so, dass bei diesen ganzen Dingen sich die Idee in den Köpfen der, ich weiß nicht, Politiker, Herrscher, wie auch immer man das nennen will, fest setzt, dass man diese ganze Frage irgendwie so klärt. Beispiel ist die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. In Deutschland gab es mal eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung, dann ist die in den Gesetz gegossen worden, dann hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt, so, nee Leute, so geht es nicht. Wir können es euch nicht generell verbieten, aber das Gesetz muss auf jeden Fall anders sein. So jetzt ist es gerade wieder so, dass es wieder von vorne losgeht. Also Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist doch eigentlich eine gute Sache. Wenn ich mir jetzt ACTA angucke, dann denke ich so, okay, möglicherweise dieser Vorstoß zu Ende, aber was passiert dann?
Also ACTA ist ja schon der zweite Vorstoß.
Mit diesen Inhalten.
Wird ihr jetzt trotzdem nicht... Es kommt ein dritter. Ich wollte gerade sagen, es ist nicht das Ende.
Nein, es ist nicht das Ende. Man muss schauen, wo kommen diese Forderungen, die jetzt schon alle rausverhandelt worden sind, sind eigentlich alle her. Die kommen sowohl aus den Staaten als auch aus der Europäischen Union. Es gibt ein Papier, das ist auch veröffentlicht, wo ganz klar die Aufgabenbeschreibung der Verhandlungsgruppe der Europäischen drinnen stand, was sie haben wollen. Das war halt Three-Strikes-Regelung, das waren Saturatory Damages. All diese Dinge stehen schon seit Jahren zur Debatte und zwar zuletzt sollten die in AIPRED II, das ist eine Direktiv auf europäischer Ebene, verankert werden. Das ist die Intellectual Property Rights Enforcement Directive.
Gesundheit?
Ja, Enforcement ist so mein Lieblingswort dabei. Die gibt es schon, das ist die Implementation des TRIP-Abkommens. Ja, wir haben hier echt Internationalprojekte, das ist großartig, alles Verträge. Das ist quasi die weltweite Regelung über Urheberrecht und Verwertungsrecht. Das ist das TRIP-Abkommen. Was aber uralt ist. Das ist uralt, das ist jetzt nichts Neues. Wo übrigens auch nur drinsteht, dass es 50 Jahre nach dem Tod Schutz geben muss. Inzwischen ist fast überall 70 Jahre. Und dann sagt man, da können wir nicht zurück, weil es ja das TRIP-Abkommen ist. Was wir nicht umstoßen können. Naja, dann müsste man aber wenigstens auf 50 Jahre zurückgehen können.
Okay, also die Verwertungsschutzfristen, da kommen wir später nochmal genauer zu. Aber es ist jetzt so, ACTA ist quasi ein, obwohl wir hier gerade über ein riesiges, komplexes Konstrukt reden, ist ACTA quasi nur eine praktische Ausführung einer Politik, die noch lange nicht beendet ist.
Genau, weil jetzt kommt, ist die Roadmap veröffentlicht worden, zur Novellierung von AIPRAD, weil AIPRAD 2 ist damals gescheitert. Und in dieser Roadmap stehen genau die Sachen, die wir rauslobbyiert haben, alle wieder drinnen. Also die ganzen Punkte aus ACTA, die wir rauslobbyiert haben und rausprotestiert haben, stehen alle wieder auf der Roadmap für Europa in der Novellierung der AIPRAD-Richtlinie.
Also das ist jetzt sozusagen eine Frage, die hat jetzt nicht mehr generell was mit dem Thema zu tun, aber stößt mir jetzt doch gerade auf. Ist es als Aktivist nicht irgendwie so, dass man dann irgendwann denkt, so jetzt hab ich aber eigentlich die Faxen dicke? Weil für mich sieht das ja noch so eine Zermürbungstaktik aus. So man protestiert dagegen, dann kippen wir das, dann denken wir uns eine neue, vier Buchstangen-Abkürzung auf, und dann wird alles total super. Ist es schwierig, die Motivation für sowas aufrechtzuerhalten und das trotzdem zu machen?
Also ich mach das ja jetzt noch nicht so lange. Also erst irgendwie seit zweieinhalb, drei Jahren. Noch geht's, aber ich würde mich freuen, wenn diejenigen, die sich eh schon drum kümmern, es vielleicht irgendwann nicht mehr so intensiv tun müssen, und irgendwie vielleicht ein paar Hörerinnen und Hörer einfach sich überlegen, hey, vielleicht kann ich helfen, und auch einfach ein bisschen diese Verantwortung mittragen, dagegen zu lobbyieren, Leute zu mobilisieren, zu Demos zu gehen oder Abgeordnete anzurufen. Das wär total geil, wenn es einfach ein paar mehr werden. Also ich sehe es nicht ganz so pessimistisch. Ich bin ja schon etwas älter. Ich war 99 ja schon aktiv, oder da bin ich eigentlich aktiv geworden. Da ging es um Netzsperren in Nordrhein-Westfalen in seiner Zeit. Und da waren wirklich in Düsseldorf vor dem Landtag, da habe ich dann auch so Leute kennengelernt, wie den Föhrbot oder den CCC. Da war so ein Dutzend Leute gefühlt, mit so einem Transparent. Da kann man auch Fotos im Internet suchen und finden. Inzwischen, bei der letzten Runde ACTA-Demos, da waren in Deutschland wirklich weit über 100.000 Leute unterwegs. Da sieht man ja, dass man nicht falsch lag. Mich motiviert das schon, dass immer mehr Leute jetzt auch sagen, die so, aber nicht. Ich finde es motivierend, dass so viele Leute mitmachen jetzt schon. Aber die Proteste sind ja nur dann jetzt die Spitze. Es ist auch total super, wie viele YouTube-Videos es gibt, wie viele Blogbeiträge. Das ist alles auch total motivierend. Aber diese durchgehende Lobbyarbeit in Brüssel für ein freies Netz, das ist ja nicht nur, wenn es akut wird, sondern durchgehend eigentlich muss diese Arbeit gemacht werden. Das wäre schön, wenn da ein bisschen mehr Unterstützung da wäre.
Jetzt ist es ja so, dass ich wegen dieser Lobbyarbeit gründet sich ja gerade für eine wie die Digitale Gesellschaft, die das mal machen wollen. Ich möchte eine Sache dazusagen, Herr Obach und Naha sagen immer, geht demonstrieren, geht demonstrieren. Der erste Schritt finde ich, ist immer informiert euch. Gerade bei solchen Themen sollte man sich schon eine eigene Meinung bilden. Hört euch zum Beispiel dieses Chaosradio an, beleset euch dazu. Das muss man manchmal sagen, weil ich glaube, viele Leute sitzen zu Hause vor ihren neuartigen Grundfunkumfangsgeräten und haben, egal für welche Seite ihr so den Anspruch, dass sie sagen so, ja, sagt uns mal, was wir machen sollen. Und ich glaube, es ist eine andere Sache, wenn man auf die Straße geht, weil man das im Radio gehört hat, da sind zwar Leute, die klingen irgendwie cool, die so auf die Straße gehen, dann mach ich das jetzt mal, als wenn man das sozusagen tatsächlich verstanden hat, worum es geht und sich dann dafür entscheidet.
Aber das versteht man doch. Ich meine, über 70 Prozent haben Internetanschluss, die konsumieren Sachen aus dem Internet, die treffen auf diese schrecklichen YouTube-Stopper, wo es dann heißt, es ist in ihrem Land nicht verfügbar. Also ich meine, das muss doch jetzt jeder merken.
Ich möchte ja nur dafür ein Plädoyer abgeben, dass die Leute sozusagen nicht den Kopf abgeben sollen an der Kasse. Wenn sich jetzt jemand informiert und entschieden hat, ich möchte da auch dagegen was machen und ich möchte mehr machen als am 9. Juni auf die Straße gehen, was sind denn so ganz praktische Dinge, die ich jetzt ohne viel Vorwissen machen kann? Also ich höre immer wieder Abgeordnete anrufen. Für mich sind Abgeordnete so Leute in den Wolken da oben. Ich kann den Journalisten auch anfragen. Schwierig genug bei denen Termin zu kriegen. Wie ruf ich die denn an, um ihnen zu sagen? Die Nummer? Es geht an.
Abgeordnetenwatch, da kann man mit ein paar Klicks erstmal schon mal was reinschreiben. Aber wirklich für Brüssel anrufen, die freuen sich total, weil die kommen sich total verlassen vor. Also ich hab das auch schon ein paar Mal gemacht. Die freuen sich, wenn Bürger anrufen oder Bürger nämlich gewählt hat.
Plötzlich interessiert er sich für mich.
Das ist für die total ungewohnt, also wirklich ungewohnt. Und es ist einfach wirklich die Nummer anrufen. Es gibt so, lack of a better student, also Jeremy Zimmermann, seinem Account folgen auf Twitter. Er ruft immer wieder auf, ruft an. Da gibt es auch Leitfaden, Telefonleitfaden, Argumentationsleitfäden in verschiedenen Sprachen. Es gibt Listen von Abgeordneten, nur den deutschsprachigen Abgeordneten oder den französischen oder den britischen. Und auch, also es ist Material da. Es ist Material da.
Aber man kann mit denen auch tatsächlich sprechen. Es ist nicht so, ich quatsche dann auf eine Mailbox und die wird dann einfach einmal monatelöscht.
Vielleicht auch mit dem Mitarbeiter, das ist aber auch okay. Dann sprecht auch mit dem Mitarbeiter, weil die geben das wirklich weiter. Und die freuen sich. Es ist halt wichtig zu wissen, sind sie gerade in Brüssel oder in Straßburg? Aber das kann man im Kalender nachschauen. Bisher wird auch immer mitgeteilt, wo man jetzt gerade anrufen muss. Es gibt zu allen Sachen, gibt es Listen. Also im La Quarta Tutu Net Wiki sind die Listen alle aufgeführt. Es ist auch immer wieder, gerade bei diesen europäischen Themen, kann man da immer ganz auf der Startseite vorne finden, was ist gerade akut, was muss gerade gemacht werden, wo kann ich helfen.
Das geht also ganz praktisch. Jetzt haben wir eine Stunde lang erklärt, was ACTA ist und warum der Chaos Computer Club und andere Aktivisten meinen, dass es nicht so eine geile Idee ist und was man dagegen machen kann. Wir werden uns jetzt gleich mal mit der anderen Seite der Medaille beschäftigen, denn es geht ja im Hintergrund immer um dieses Verwertungsrecht, um dieses Kopieren, um diese Dinge, die da im Netz Leute einfach hin und her tauschen. Eine kleine musikalische Pause und dann geht's genau damit weiter.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Diese Musik ist ein weiteres Zeichen dafür, dass man beim Chaosradio gut mitmachen kann. Nicht nur anrufen, wir fragen nämlich vor dem Chaosradio im Blumen hier auf Ritz immer nach, ob ihr bestimmte Creative Commons Musik hören wollt. Könnt ihr dann gerne auf Twitter Bescheid sagen. Diese hier kommt vom Kraftfutter Mischwerk und Bastion heißt am Wolkenberg und gibt es auch zum Runterladen. Den Link gibt es vielleicht dann irgendwann im Blog zur Sendung. Wir sprechen heute hier im Chaosradio über diesen Streit, der im und durchs Internet geht, wo es darum geht, dass Leute verhindern wollen, dass ihr einfach so Sachen kopiert. Andere Leute denken so, naja kopiert doch ruhig, wir müssen trotzdem irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass die Künstler vielleicht Geld kriegen. Das klären wir heute hier. Und den ersten Teil hatten wir gerade abgeschlossen. Da ging es um ACTA, ein Handelsabkommen, was sozusagen von der einen extremen Seite kommt, wo Leute sagen, lass das Internet einfach überwachen. Das ist doch total super, dann kopiert auch keiner mehr. Jetzt haben wir gerade noch einen Anruf bekommen, deswegen ziehen wir das Thema noch ein kleines Stückchen weiter von Florian aus Karlsruhe, der ist aktives Mitglied bei den Grünen und will erzählen, wie er diese Debatte wahrnimmt. Hallo Florian. So, du bist also aktiv dabei oder du bist nur aktiv bei den Grünen und kriegst das so am Rande mit?
Na ja, ich bin sehr aufgeregt, ich bin hauptsächlich aktiv in der Grünen Jugend, aber auch in der Partei und wollte nur mal so ein bisschen erzählen, wie das aus meiner Sicht läuft und...
Ja, du musst keine Angst haben, wir beißen dir nicht den Kopf ab, aber wir hören dir gerne gespannt zu, wie du das erzählst, also wie genau begegnet es da und was passiert da innerhalb der Partei bei dir?
Genau, also ich hab halt mitbekommen, dass ACTA nicht so eine große Rolle gespielt hat, bevor es so im Februar dann mit dieser großen Demo richtig hochgekocht ist, aber seitdem spielt es auch bei uns im Verband eine ziemlich große Rolle und wir hatten dann in Reaktion auf die ACTA-Debatte einen Beschluss gefasst, als Grüne Jugendfeuer auf Bundesebene zum Urheberrecht, wo wir uns klar positionieren, dass wir sagen, so dieser Weg, den ACTA einschlägt, zu verbieten und das Kopierungshindern zu wollen, ist kein Weg und es führt kein Weg dran vorbei, das Filesharing zu legalisieren und wir gehen noch auf viel weiteres ein, wir gehen darauf ein, dass wir es für notwendig halten, dass mir nicht Apple vorschreibt, Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich die freundliche Freiheit, was ich irgendwie auf meinem iPod installieren darf und...
Okay, also da geht es sozusagen um die ganz große Freiheit. Der kleine interessante Punkt, auf den ich gerade aufmerksam geworden bin, ist, du hast gesagt, was hat bei euch erst dann eine Rolle gespielt, als die großen Demonstrationen schon am Start waren. Herr Obach hebt gerade beide Finger. Möchtest du dazu etwas?
Ja, ich hab das bei den Grünen durchaus anders erlebt. Also sowohl Jan Albrecht als auch die Skala Keller aus dem Europäischen Parlament, die ja auch viel noch mit den Grünen im Bund zu tun haben, haben da ständig darauf hingewiesen. Auch die Netzpolitiker der Grünen, also Malte Spitz zum Beispiel oder auch Konstantin von Notz, haben immer wieder darauf hingewiesen, aber auch in der Partei hat ihnen einfach keiner zugehört. Es war sehr spannend gewesen. Also es ist einfach nicht nach unten durchgedrungen. Also ich hab das sehr viel mitbekommen. Auf Twitter haben die sehr viel darüber gesprochen, Vorträge, Blogbeiträge, alles. Aber es ist leider nicht nach unten durchgedrungen. Das ist mein Empfinden von außen jetzt, also nicht involviert bei den Grünen.
Florian, ihr habt dann diesen Entschluss gefasst. Wie ist der dann aufgenommen worden? Also von da, wo du aktiv bist?
Ich wollte gerade noch kurz anmelken zum Herrn Urbach. Absolut. Also klar gibt es bei den Grünen auch Leute, die sich sehr früh da eingemischt haben. Aber genau so diese Durchbringung fehlt. Also es waren halt immer so die paar Netzpolitiker. Und zwar halt nicht so die breite Basis. Und so diesen Beschluss, also ich habe den Eindruck, dass er relativ positiv aufgenommen wird mit Leuten, mit denen ich mich drüber unterhalte, also auch über Parteigrenzen hinweg bei Leuten, die halt so diese Einsicht teilen, dass es halt der falsche Weg ist, das Kopieren zu bekämpfen. Und was halt unsere Intention hauptsächlich war, als wir den Antrag verfasst haben, ich bin einer der Mitautoren unserer Intention, war uns in die Partei Interne-Debatte einzumischen, die gerade läuft und die jetzt dann im Sommer oder Herbst, ich glaube, da gibt es noch keinen finalen Termin, wird es bei den Grünen eine große Konferenz geben in Berlin zum Thema Urheberrecht, wo dann halt das ausbalanciert werden soll, welches ja halt so einerseits gibt es eben die Netzpolitiker, wie Malte, wie JPA, wie Konstantin von Notz und so weiter. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es halt so diese, ähm, ich will jetzt nichts irgendwie undeklomatisches sagen. Ja, die halt so diese Sache von irgendwas müssen, die können sie doch leben und wir müssen irgendwie das Kopieren verhindern. Und die sollen doch bitte alle bei iTunes oder am besten noch irgendwie so auf CD oder Vinyl ihre Musik kaufen.
Okay, ich möchte jetzt aber zzt. sagen, weil diese Schleife wollten wir in der Sendung eh gerade machen. Es ist ja die eine Sache, dass man sagt, okay, da wird so viel kopiert, lass mal irgendwie das Internet absperren. Die andere Seite ist ja, dass es eigentlich noch viel zu wenig konkrete Vorschläge gibt, wie die Leute, deren Musik kopiert wird, doch zu Geld kommen könnten. Hast du da nicht jetzt zwei Fragen sozusagen aus deiner grünen Perspektive? Findet ihr überhaupt, dass die Künstler irgendwie Geld bekommen sollten? Und wenn ja, habt ihr eine Idee, wie das gehen kann?
Erster Hinweis, ich fühle mich nicht dafür zuständig, mir Geschäftsmodelle auszudenken. Ich mache Politik und ich mache keine Geschäftsmodelle für wen auch immer. Zweiter Hinweis, wir fordern als grüne Jugend schon lange ein bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen, von dem jeder Mensch armutsfest, unabhängig davon, ob er an der Erwerbsarbeit nachgeht oder nicht, leben kann. Aus dieser Perspektive halte ich auch diese Debatte um die sogenannte Kulturflatrate oder Kulturwertmark, die auch bei den Grünen relativ intensiv geführt wird, eigentlich für nicht besonders zielführend.
Du sagst, das Problem klärt sich ganz von selber, wenn einfach die Leute alle Geld kriegen, unabhängig davon, was sie machen.
Ich sage nicht, dass sich das Problem von alleine klärt. Ich sage, es wird natürlich Änderungen im Musikmarkt geben und allgemein, aber ich meine, die gab es schon immer. Und einfach zu sagen, wir wollen den Status Quo aus den 90er Jahren irgendwie behalten und ziehen das mit aller Gewalt durch, das finde ich halt nicht besonders sinnvoll. Also bestimmt wird...
Ich möchte halt, dass Sie sich schon unterbrechen, sagen, ich finde es halt genauso kurzfristig, diese Meinung zu vertreten und dann keinen Gegenvorschlag zu haben.
Gegenvorschlag für was?
Genau. Also den Leuten einfach zu sagen, okay, das gültigerecht ist jetzt zwar so am Start, aber das gilt jetzt halt nicht mehr, also so wie du klarkommst. Das ist halt keine gute Diskussionsgrundlage. Das kann man als Ansicht zwar vertreten, aber ich glaube, so als Diskussionsgrundlage ist es eher nicht so hilfreich.
Nein, ich meine, es wird doch weiterhin auch einen Markt für Musik geben. Und was ich mal klarstellen will, es fordert sich auch quasi niemand, das Urheberrecht komplett abzuschaffen, mal außer einzelnen Leuten, sondern es geht halt so um das nicht-kommerzielle Filesharing. Und natürlich wird es bald den Leuten geben, die Geld ausgeben wollen. Man guckt sich Flatter an, also es gibt Leute, die bei Flatter irgendwie richtig gut abfahren. Also wenn man sich mal anguckt, was Tim Pritloff da irgendwie kriegt, okay, das ist ein einzelnes Basis.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist der berühmte Einzelfall.
Flatter auch bekannt als der Tim-Pritloff-Finanzierungsfund. Aber ich sehe schon, das bedarf auf jeden Fall noch mal genauerer perspektivischer Darstellung. Flöre, an dir erstmal vielen Dank für den Einblick in die Perspektive. Und viel Spaß noch. Und jetzt würde ich nämlich euch fragen, weil da wollten wir gerade hin. Flöre hat zwar gesagt, ja, also diese ganze Sache mit der Kulturwertmark, das ist ja möglicherweise gar nicht so spannend, aber das ist tatsächlich ein Modell, was ja vom Club auch kommt, nämlich eine neue Idee, wie man möglicherweise Künstler finanzieren könnte.
Ja, genau. Also erstmal soll das nicht die einzige Möglichkeit sein. Florian hat es ja schon angesprochen. Es geht um das nicht-kommerzielle Filesharing, was damit eben weiterhin problemlos, straffrei, legal möglich sein soll. Und es geht nicht darum jetzt irgendwie zu sagen, nur so können Künstler Geld verdienen. Natürlich ist es nach wie vor möglich, Geschäftsmodellen im Netz nachzugehen. Da gibt es schon eine ganze Menge. Ich will da jetzt auch nicht so viele Namen nennen, weil man dann immer Werbung macht für verschiedene Plattformen. Aber es gibt durchaus die Möglichkeit, da Geld zu verdienen. Aber jetzt geht es halt um dieses Filesharing. Und das ist auch ganz, ganz wichtig. Denn letztlich geht es da um die Privatkopie. Die Privatkopie ist etwas, was wir in Deutschland haben und was wir natürlich weiterhin sichern wollen. Und es ist auch klar, wie man das definiert. Also wie gesagt, nicht Kommerzielle Austausch, nicht unbedingt Austausch, aber Filesharing. Das ist es eben. Und das sollte auf keinen Fall irgendwie eingeschränkt werden. Hier schreibt sogar jemand im Pad, Filesharing sei das neue Radio. Also klar, das brauchen wir. Gleichzeitig müssen natürlich auch Urheber irgendwie Geld bekommen.
Wichtiger Punkt glaube ich, weil in der Diskussion werden ja immer diese Extreme dargestellt. Aber es ist schon sozusagen auch ein größerer Konsens, dass ihr sagt, Leute, die Musik machen, sollen schon auch was verdienen können damit.
Ja, weil jetzt sage ich noch eben schon den dritten Punkt, auf den es unbedingt ankommt. Also ich glaube, es gibt drei wichtige Punkte, um die wir nicht herumherum können. Und ich glaube, es gibt auch niemanden, der das anders sieht. Also auch unter den schlimmsten Nomisten, die sagen auch immer, die Urheber sollen Geld bekommen. Und die werden auch jetzt nicht sagen, wir schaffen die Privatkopie ab. Und der dritte Punkt ist sicherlich umstritten. Also es darf keine Überwachungsinfrastruktur geben im Internet. Also dass man in jedes Paket reinschaut, das geht eben einfach nicht in einem freien Land. Das ist glaube ich auch ein breiter Konsens, auch wenn man von Urheber oder Verwertungsrechtler da manchmal was anderes hört. Also das sind die drei Punkte, auf die es ankommt. Jetzt die Frage, wie macht man es? Und jetzt gab es ja diesen Vorschlag der Kulturflatrate, der ist in gewisser Weise problematisch. Erstmal Zwangsabgabe, gut, aber wir haben natürlich auch jetzt schon Zwangsabgaben. Und der nächste Punkt ist halt, das soll dann irgendwie verteilt werden nach irgendwelchen Schlüsseln. Da ist ja die Erfahrung in der Vergangenheit auch nicht so gut mit den Schlüsseln. Und deshalb wäre es eben besser, wenn es eine Möglichkeit gäbe, wo Nutzer selber entscheiden können. Der und der soll eben Geld bekommen. Also ein bisschen wie bei Flatter eben. Nur eben Flatter im großen Stil. Und das ist eben die Idee der Kulturwertmark.
Herr Halt, wie bei Flatter im großen Stil ist keine zulässige Erklärung.
Ja gut, ich hab's ja versucht ein bisschen... Und jetzt Flatter erklären, ja? Okay.
Das ist UKB-Radio.
Ach so.
Nicht alle neben den ganzen Tag im Netz. Also dann...
Erklär mal Flatter. Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Wartet mal. Wir müssen glaub ich einfach nicht Flatter erklären, sondern erklärt einfach mal die Kulturwertmark. Von jemand, der Flatter, für jemand, der Flatter nicht kennt.
Also ich zahle im, also ich zahle im Monat einen Betrag. Ich sagen wir jetzt mal, nur um eine Hausnummer zu nennen, 50 Euro. Dafür bekomme ich eine gewisse Anzahl Kulturwertmarken. Sagen wir jetzt einfach mal zehn Stück. Das sind jetzt keine fixen Zahlen, das sind nur für ein Beispiel. Also jetzt surfe ich durchs Netz und finde eine Band, die ich total geil finde. Oder ein Buch. Oder ein Buch, das ich total geil finde. Oder eine Mischung aus alledem. Oh mein Gott, krasses Musikvideo, das ist ein Kurzfilm, mit einem Buch dabei. Und ich bin jetzt der Meinung, ich möchte diesen Menschen, weil ich es mir runtergeladen habe, Geld dafür geben. Also ich kann jetzt ihm einfach eine Kulturwertmarke geben.
Also das ist dann sozusagen irgendwie auf der Webseite implementiert. Da klickt man was und dann wandert da.
Da kann man sich verschiedene Modelle vorstellen. Das kann man auf der Webseite machen, oder wie ein Kleinschreiben, was auch immer. Das ist auch noch nicht fix. Ich gebe ihm diese Kulturwertmarke. Am Ende des Moors hat er eine gute... Wertmark, nicht Wertmark. Wertmark wie D-Mark. Wertmark, Weinfehler. So, das heißt, ich habe ihm jetzt quasi 5 Euro gegeben. Von meinen 10 Stück, die haben 50 Euro gekostet, sind 5 Euro. Und hier sag ich noch all meinen Kumpels, hier guckt mal wie geil und davon sagen auch noch 5 weitere, finde ich gut. Der kriegt von mir meinen Kulturwertmark. Einer zahlt eine, andere vielleicht drei. Also ganz unterschiedlich. Und am Ende des Moors hat dann der Künstler eine gewisse Summe Kulturwertmark. Und die kriegt er dann gegen wahres getauscht. Also kannste wieder zurücktauschen. Ich hab also mir die Kunst runtergeladen. Ich hab den Künstler entlohnt. Und zwar ganz direkt ohne irgendwelche Zwischenschritte, wie das dann irgendwie 10% Verwaltungsgebühren abfallen oder dergleichen, sondern ganz direkt. Und er bekommt seine Entlohnung. Und zwar dann, weil mir das Werk auch wirklich gefallen hat. Also ich wollte es halt haben.
Also nur um das klarzustellen, es geht nicht darum, dass ich dann Musik nur runterladen darf, wenn ich demjenigen so eine Kulturwertmark gebe, sondern ich darf mir hier alle Musik aus dem Netz runterladen für meinen privaten Gebrauch. Genau. Und zahle aber pflichtgemäß, also muss diesen Anteil zahlen und kann den aber frei verteilen?
Ich kann den frei verteilen, genau.
Okay, aber ich muss ihn zahlen.
Also es gibt die, sofern ich das Konzept richtig verstanden habe, gibt es die Idee, dass jeder Bundesbürger oder jeder, der hier lebt, diese Kulturwertmarken am Anfang des Morals bekommt. Ja, das ist noch nicht richtig ausdiskutiert, ob das über den Internetanschluss geht oder vielleicht auch, man könnte sogar, also es spricht nichts dagegen zu sein, wir machen das komplett freiwillig. Wer das macht, der hat eben das gute Gefühl, ich mache hier Legales und alles ist schön. Also ich würde sogar am Anfang sagen, bevor man jetzt sagt, es ist wieder der Zwangsabgabe, man fängt damit einfach mal an und wer macht es, der macht. Einfach so. Aber es gibt natürlich auch die Vorstellung, dass man sagt, wir binden das an den Internetanschluss, wer einen Internetanschluss hat, der soll sich beteiligen. Der kriegt dann vielleicht irgendwie so einen Zugang und dann ist gut.
Und wenn ich sozusagen zu faul bin zum Klicken oder einfach ein kleiner Verpeiler, dann sammel ich ganz viele Kulturwertmarken auf meinem Konto?
Genau und du verteilst halt nicht, weil du verpeilst die ganze Zeit. Aber am Ende des Mords ist ja klar, wie viele Kulturwertmark verteilt worden sind. Und nehmen wir mal an, deine 10 Stück sind noch da. Die verfallen dann. Die kannst du also nicht sammeln. Du sammelst einen großen Haufen. Und die, die ausgegeben worden sind, aber nicht verteilt wurden, werden dann prozentual an die, die schon welche bekommen haben, nochmal verteilt.
Okay, aber hat man dann nicht auch das klassische Problem, wer eh schon viel hat, bekommt noch mehr?
Ja, das ist in gewisser Weise ein Problem. Also das ist eben das Tim Pertloff-Prinzip. Wo man sagt, was hinterher alle vielleicht erpointen, dass sie bei Tim Pertloff sind. So kann es natürlich auch hier passieren. Dass, also bei Flatter ist ja noch das Problem, dass die Leute ihr Flattergeld dann auch weiter flattern und so. Dass es so eine Art Delegationskette gibt bis zu einer Person. Das muss natürlich so nicht realisiert werden. Aber es kann schon sein, dass natürlich bestimmte Leute sehr viel bekommen, weil sie irgendwie auch sehr netzaffin sind und so. Und immer darauf hinweisen und so und andere weniger. Das ist natürlich schon in gewisser Weise ein Problem. Aber ich denke, das ist immer noch besser als das bisherige Modell, wo ja auch Geld verteilt wird, zum Beispiel über die GEMA. Und die hat aber schon solche Schlüssel, wo auch bestimmte Leute viel kriegen und andere Leute weniger. Und es ist halt auch, es ist zwar nicht intransparent, weil die GEMA ja ihre Sachen erlaufen nicht, aber so richtig schön ist das auch nicht. Und so richtig, naja, also das ist auch kein wirklich gutes Modell. Also dann finde ich es schon besser, wenn letztlich die Nutzer selber entscheiden können. Außerdem ist es datensparsam, auch das ist nochmal ein Punkt.
Aber es muss ja irgendwie festgestellt werden, wie viel, also oder nicht andersrum. Es wird sagen, es wird gar nicht gemessen, wie viel Down runtergeladen wurde.
Genau, das brauchen wir dann nicht mehr zu messen. Wir brauchen keine Überwachung mehr im Internet. Das ist ja gerade das Geniale.
Okay, das heißt aber, wenn jemand total viel getauscht wird, hat er nichts davon, von der Kulturwertmark?
Stückweise nicht, wenn die Leute ihm nichts geben, aber das kann eigentlich nicht sein. Jemand, der wirklich große Aufmerksamkeit erregt und viel bekannt ist und auf jedem Schulhof wird das getauscht, der hat natürlich dann auch wahrscheinlich viele Kulturwertmark.
Aber wahrscheinlich, du sagst, es gibt keine Kopplung.
Ja gut, also wenn es wirklich über den Anschluss geht, also wenn ich die Bezahlung, den Anschluss, dass ich halt diese Kulturwertmark mitkaufen muss, dann ist halt die Sache, ich hab dann das Zeug zu Hause rumfliegen. Also ich hab dann diese Kulturwertmark und ich kann sie ausgeben und ich kann sie liegen lassen. Und wenn ich schon die Chance habe, dann runterzuladen und zu verteilen, weil ich sie sowieso habe, weil ich nicht erst noch extra kaufen gehen muss. Ich muss nicht in den Laden gehen, wo online was klicken, sondern sie sind halt schon da. Das ist glaube ich der große Vorteil. Also ich habe ein Zahlungsmittel, das ich sowieso haben muss.
Ich werde meine eigene Bände und überweis die Kulturwertmark an mich selber.
Ja, gut, aber das kannst du nicht beliebig machen. Also das soll natürlich an der Stelle auch nicht so gehen, dass du einfach Sockenpuppen machst und dir immer das Geld zuspielst. Also das soll ja gerade verhindert werden. Also je nachdem, entweder man macht es über Anmeldung oder man macht es mit einem Internetanschluss, aber nicht so, dass jeder beliebig jetzt sich einfach anmelden kann für seine eigene Band.
Was ich das Spannende finde, ist ja sozusagen, es geht. Das ist ja kein perfektes Konstrukt. Es ist nicht die Wahrheit, TM, sondern ein Diskussionsvorschlag, den ihr gemacht habt, wie man sowas machen könnte. Gibt es denn auch andere in der Richtung, also gibt es überhaupt denn Ideen oder Bewegungen in irgendeiner Art und Weise?
Jaja, also das andere ist ja wie gesagt das Modell der Kulturflatrate, was ja von den Grünen kommt, was im Grunde das System auch fortsetzt, wie es jetzt schon ist. Also zu sagen, dass das was völlig utopisches ist oder dass das gar nicht geht, wie manche Leute sagen, ist ja Quatsch. Ich meine, das ist genau das, was wir jetzt schon haben, mit den Abgaben für Datenträger zum Beispiel, muss man diese Leerabgabe machen, was ja jetzt auch gerade erhöht worden ist für USB-Sticks irgendwie. Wenn die viel mehr Speicherplatz haben, werden die plötzlich teurer. Ja, das gibt es halt schon und das soll eben erweitert werden. Also nicht nur eben möglicherweise auf solche Datenträger, sondern vielleicht auch auf Internet-Anstüsse. Und das ist eben das andere Modell. Das ist halt mit weniger Freiwilligkeit und im bisherigen System, auch wieder mit Verteilungsschlüssel und so, wo man tatsächlich dann Statistiken machen muss und auch überwachen muss, wie viel wo runtergeladen wird, um das eben einigermaßen gerecht verteilen zu können. Ansonsten gibt es auch halt die Idee, also Richtung To-flat-rate aber die Verteilungsschlüssel zu ändern. Also ohne Überwachung. Wir kennen es ja von der GEMA, die verteilt wirklich viele Millionen nach sehr obskuren Verteilungsschlüsseln. Und die sind ein Problem, die Verteilungsschlüssel, wie sie momentan existieren.
Kann man das irgendwie kurz zusammenfassen?
Momentan bekommen die, die eh schon viel verkaufen, auch das meiste von der GEMA ab. Also gerade kleine Künstler, die vielleicht nicht charten im großem Stil, also in den Top 100 Charts, und die auch nicht die großen Verkäufe haben, bekommen ungleich viel, viel weniger als ein Top 10 Künstler.
Sie bekommen nicht nur weniger, weil sie weniger gespielt werden, sondern sie kommen sozusagen im Vergleich weniger.
Sie kommen auch im Vergleich weniger, ja. Und wenn es da ordentlich Verteilschlüssel gäbe, wäre das ganze Thema auch nicht mehr ganz so schlimm, wie es momentan ist. Und man kann sich also vorstellen, dass man die Leerträgerabgabe besser verteilt, dass er unsere Privatkopie sichern soll. Und da muss halt die GEMA grundlegend reformiert werden, für was wahrscheinlich aber nicht so schnell passieren wird.
Was?
Denn die GEMA, darf man nicht vergessen, ist zwar übernimmt eine staatliche Aufgabe wahr, ist aber keine staatliche Behörde oder staatliche Stelle, sondern ist eine Körperschaft des öffentlichen Rechts. Die wurde per Erlass gegründet.
Du sagst gerade so, als möchte ich sofort wissen, was das bedeutet.
Also wir kennen das ja, Behörden gehören irgendwie zu Exekutive dazu. Also zu der ausführenden Gewalt im Staat. Und wir haben in Deutschland die Tradition, dass wir viel auf Selbstregulierung setzen. Und deswegen gibt es Erlasse, die Vereine gründen. Wie zum Beispiel die GEMA oder auch die Kammern sind auch per Erlass gegründet worden. Die IHK und sowas. Wo dann die Menschen, um die es geht, drin Mitglied werden können. Und sich dann quasi selbst verwalten. Und die GEMA ist auch so ein Produkt der Selbstverwaltung der Musiker. Und das ist aber leider schon vor Jahren gehörig in die Hosen gegangen.
Das heißt, im Prinzip wäre es möglicherweise denkbar, dass man da aber was Neues gründet?
Ja sicher. Wie gesagt, es gibt ja jetzt Strukturen. Es gibt diese Zentralstelle für private Überspielrechte. ZPÜ, die übernimmt ja die Verteilung jetzt für die Privatkopie. Das ist eine Zentralstelle, bei der die Verwertungsgesellschaften alle zusammenlaufen sozusagen. Die sitzt auch bei der GEMA. Ja, und wie gesagt, die macht die Verteilung. Und die Frage ist halt, ja, wenn man jetzt so eine Kulturwertmark einführt, will man da unbedingt die ZPÜ verwenden? Oder möchte man da vielleicht besser eine neue Instanz schaffen? Ja, beziehungsweise die ZPÜ ist ja auch nicht das Problem. Da sind die Verwertungsgesellschaften wieder Mitglied. Also GEMA, VG, Word. Und dass die halt schlecht verteilen. Also die ZPÜ verteilt sogar noch recht fair auf die verschiedenen Lärträger. Wir haben ja nicht nur auf Datenträger, sondern auch auf Kopiergeräte diese Abgabe. Die ist ja auch auf Kopiergeräte, die ist auf Computer, die ist auf Laserdrucker, auf Scanner, also auf Festplatten, Bildträger, was auch immer ein Bildträger ist, CD-Rolling, auf alles Mögliche. Und dementsprechend verteilen die auch dann natürlich an die VG, Word, an die GEMA und an andere, je nachdem was für ein Bereich diese Leerträger stammen. Und dann haben die wieder das Verteilproblem. Und das verteilt sich nach diesen bekannten Schlüsseln.
Okay, das heißt, die Idee, dass man möglicherweise eine Alternative für dieses Konzept findet, ist nicht so abwegig. Und wir werden jetzt gleich nach dem Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr mit jemandem sprechen, der tatsächlich versucht, eine Alternative zur GEMA auf die Beine zu stellen. Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon auf Fritz, zu Gast sind vom Chaos Computer Club Maha und Herr Urbach. Hallo und willkommen zurück. Und es geht heute um den Kopierkulturkampf. Kurz lassen sich die ersten anderthalb Stunden der Sendung so zusammenfassen. Der Chaos Computer Club findet es nicht so geil, wenn Leute Gesetze bauen oder Handelsabkommen abschließen, die geheim sind und dann dazu führen, dass das Internet irgendwie überwacht und eingeschränkt wird, nur damit Leute nicht kopieren können. Aber ich finde es eine gute Idee, wenn Künstler, deren Zeug kopiert wird, irgendwie Geld verdienen können. Den ersten, wir haben beides geklärt. Also wir haben über das Handelsabkommen ACTA gesprochen, was genau dieses Ziel hatte und wie der Prozess dagegen organisiert ist und aus welchen Gründen. Und B haben wir über das Ding gesprochen, das sich da Kulturwertmark nennt und was so eine Idee ist, wie man möglicherweise dieses Internetkopie und doch Geld für die Künstler zusammenbringen können. Wir schaffen es jetzt nicht nochmal ganz zusammenzufassen, aber diese Sendung wird es auch als Podcast geben und da könnt ihr das ganz genau nachhören. Jetzt wollten wir, weil wir dann zum Schluss auch auf die GEMA zu sprechen kamen, mal darüber reden, ob es eine Alternative geben muss. Ist das denn generell sowas wie GEMA und ZPÜ? Wie heißt das nochmal?
Zentralstelle für private Überspielrechte.
VG-Wort. Sind die so alt und verknöchert, dass es gar keine andere Wahl mehr gibt, als da was Neues zu bauen? Oder ist es auch für euch denkbar, also pragmatisch denkbar, dass man das von innen umändert?
Also die GEMA-Strukturen sind sehr verknöchert. Also im Vorstand der GEMA sitzt ein Herr Bohlen, der auch gleichzeitig gut daran verdient. Also es fällt Künstlern sehr schwer in der GEMA irgendwas zu wegen. Also auch die Künstler, die da sind, die sagen, das geht so nicht mehr. Also auch die größten Künstler, die sagen, dass die Kleinen zu wenig abbekommen in der Verteilung, die schaffen das nicht zu ändern. Natürlich wurden da großartig Freunde geschaffen für diverse Popkünstler, die man natürlich auch nur schwerlich wieder aufgeben möchte. Und von daher ist es, glaube ich eher, dass es die GEMA, sie zu renovieren, ist nahezu unmöglich. Wir brauchen Alternativen, die nachher aber auch die gleichen Aufgaben wahrnehmen dürfen wie die GEMA. Und das ist dann natürlich dann der nächste... Also erstmal brauchen wir eine Verwerterungswirtschaft, die sich um Rechte kümmert. Also zum Beispiel Airplays, dass da das Geld dann an die Künstler weiter verteilt wird und dergleichen. Aber halt natürlich auch, die dann irgendwann dieses schadliche Privileg bekommen. Also die GEMA hat ja ein Privileg, die GEMA-Vermutung. Sie darf erstmal vermuten, dass alle Musik, die aufgeführt wird, sei es im Radio, sei es im Netz, sei es auf der Bühne, von einem ihrer Künstler stammt. Und ich muss jetzt mal das Gegenteil beweisen.
Deswegen mach ich hier auch gerade die GEMA-Liste fürs Chaosradio, in dem wir nur Creative Commons Musik spielen.
Ja, aber es gibt natürlich nicht nur die GEMA, du hast es ja schon gesagt, es gibt auch noch die anderen Verwertungsgesellschaften, die bei weitem nicht so in der Kritik stehen wie die GEMA. Also es gibt da durchaus auch bessere Modelle. Also von daher würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, Verwertungsgesellschaften sind per se immer schlecht. Oder die französische Partnerorganisation der GEMA hat dort ja sogar Creative Commons mit aufgenommen und auch die Möglichkeit der Parallellizenzierung aufgenommen. Also es gibt durchaus Leute, die die Zeichen der Zeit verstanden haben. Und ich denke, früher oder später wird auch die GEMA begreifen, wo es langgeht. Das dauert bei der halt irgendwie etwas länger. Aber ich wäre jetzt nicht da immer nur pessimistisch. Also ich selbst war ja auf einem Podium in München über Urheberrecht. Und danach hat mich ein Vorstandsmitglied oder Aufsichtsleiter, ich weiß nicht genau, von der ZPÜ angesprochen, ein Prof. Becker. Und der meinte, also er könne sich sowas wie eine Kulturwertmark im Rahmen der ZPÜ durchaus auch vorstellen. Gut, das mag jetzt eine Minderheitenmeinung sein bei denen, aber man sieht, die sind jetzt nicht alle nur auf Ablehnung. Also das kann da vielleicht auch funktionieren, aber wahrscheinlich braucht es noch eine Zeit, da Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten.
Und möglicherweise geht diese Überzeugungsarbeit ein bisschen schneller, wenn doch mal jemand eine Alternative auf die Beine stellt, zum Beispiel für die GEMA. Und Mike Michalke ist einer von einem Team von Leuten, die genau das versuchen und jetzt am Telefon Hallo und guten Abend, Mike. Kannst du mal kurz erklären, was du da treibst und warum das so lange dauert?
Oh, das sind ja gleich zwei Dinge auf einmal. Also erstmal versuchen wir, tatsächlich eine alternative Verwertungsgesellschaft für Musik aufzubauen. Und die meisten, die bei uns daran arbeiten, kommen so aus dem Creative Commons Sektor. Also was uns als erstes am meisten gestört hat an der GEMA, war, dass man dort als Musiker keine Möglichkeit hat, einzelne Stücke rauszunehmen und unter einer Creative Commons Lizenz ins Netz zu stellen.
Das heißt also, wenn ich Künstler bin, der einmal bei der GEMA sich registriert hat, dann ist alles, was ich abdenke, bis ich aus der GEMA wieder austrete und auch darüber hinaus, dann sozusagen der GEMA für die Verwertung angeschrieben.
Genau, die GEMA hat quasi so ein Prozedere, dass man, wenn man dort Mitglied wird, die es ja als Verein strukturiert, dass man dann sein gesamtes Repertoire der GEMA zur Verwertung gibt und dann eben nicht einzelne Stücke wieder rausnehmen kann, um die dann getrennt davon zu lizensieren. Und das ist ja eigentlich genau quasi der Kontrapunkt, den die Creative Commons Lizenzen setzen, die halt eher so gestrickt sind, dass man für jedes einzelne Stück oder jedes einzelne Werk, um das allgemeiner zu sagen, einzeln entscheiden kann, unter welchen Bedingungen man das lizenzieren will. Und das ist eben genau das, was wir mit unserem Projekt, das nennt sich Cultural Commons Collecting Society, eben realisieren wollen.
Und habt ihr bis auf den kompliziert zu merkenden Namen noch andere Probleme? Weil ich kann mich erinnern, dass es schon sehr lange her ist, dass wir mal hier ein Interview bei Fritz hatten, als das Projekt in Angriff genommen wurde.
Ja, wir haben glaube ich vor anderthalb Jahren oder so was mal darüber gesprochen. Vor knapp zwei Jahren auf jeden Fall haben wir das Ganze veröffentlicht, einfach nur so als Idee. Und seitdem diskutieren wir quasi mit allen, die halt seitdem an uns herangetreten sind und gesagt haben, das ist eine coole Idee, halt darüber, wie man das tatsächlich realisieren kann. Es gibt halt wirklich unglaublich viele Problemfelder, mit denen man sich da beschäftigen muss. Das fängt halt an, zum Beispiel bei den gesetzlichen Grundlagen, die es für Verwertungsgesellschaften gibt. Also man braucht jetzt nicht unbedingt, wie ich gerade gehört habe, einen staatlichen Erlass oder so, um eine Verwertungsgesellschaft zu gründen, sondern es gibt das Urheberrechtswahrnehmungsgesetz, in dem zum Beispiel geregelt ist, was eine Verwertungsgesellschaft ist, wen die als Mitglied aufnimmt und wem die eine Lizenz geben muss und so weiter. Und da ist auch drin geregelt, dass das Patent- und Markenamt in München die Staatsaufsicht darüber hat. Von denen haben wir heute auch Post gekriegt. Die wissen ja auch, dass es uns gibt und die möchten jetzt gerne mehr Informationen. Und das finde ich halt zum Beispiel super, dass wir halt vom Patentamt jetzt einen Brief kriegen, in dem drin steht, ja, Sie möchten gerne eine Verwaltungsgesellschaft gründen. Bitte geben Sie uns mehr Informationen. Das funktioniert offensichtlich relativ gut mit dieser Staatsaufsicht. Und das sind halt eben so Probleme, mit denen wir uns halt beschäftigen, okay, was sind jetzt genau die Schritte? Man muss zum Beispiel, um so eine Lizenz zu bekommen, ein entsprechendes Repertoire vorweisen können. Man muss dann sagen können, wie die Verwaltungsstruktur aufgebaut sein soll. Man muss zum Beispiel auch offenlegen, wie man die Gelder verteilen will. Also in dem Gesetz ist auch geregelt, dass es tatsächlich einen definierten Schlüssel geben muss, nachdem die Gelder verteilt werden und so weiter. Und das muss jetzt halt alles nach und nach aufgebaut werden. Dafür braucht man einen wirtschaftlichen Sachverstand, juristischen Sachverstand. Und wir sammeln halt jetzt seit zwei Jahren immer mehr Leute ein, die sich genau dafür interessieren.
Und geht das dann nur für Creative Commons Musik? Oder plant ihr auch so dieses Filesharing-Problem und überhaupt das Ganze da irgendwie mit in deine Not zu bringen?
Das Filesharing-Problem, um das quasi direkt zu lösen, müsste man ja tatsächlich auf Urheberrechtsebene ansetzen oder sowas. Wir versuchen das quasi indirekt irgendwie abzufedern, dadurch, dass es halt, wenn so eine Verwertungsgesellschaft für CC-Musik existiert, es tatsächlich auch real möglich ist, darauf ein Kulturwirtschaftssystem aufzubauen, also dass dann auch große Lizenznehmer, die halt wirklich dann auch richtig viel Geld da reinspielen können, eine Stelle haben, an die sie sich wenden können mit wir haben hier eine Liste von 300 Titeln, wir brauchen dafür eine Lizenz. Das ist halt im Augenblick eigentlich total unpraktikabel für wirklich größere Lizenznehmer, wie zum meinetwegen Clubs oder große Unternehmen, die einfach viele Titel für eine Werbekampagne oder sowas benutzen wollen. Die müssen im Augenblick halt für jeden einzelnen Track, den die verwenden wollen, erst mal rausfinden, wer sind die Urheber davon und dann mit denen einzelne Verträge aushandeln und so weiter und das ist halt unglaublich langartig. Deswegen ist das für die einfach nicht besonders attraktiv. Die gehen dann halt lieber gleich zur GEMA, da haben die halt diese eine Stelle und bezahlen da einmal dann halt die ausgerechnete Lizenzgebühr und dann sind die halt zufrieden.
Das heißt, eure Verwaltungswirtschaft richtet sich gezielt nur an die großen Player?
Nicht gezielt nur, sondern sie richtet sich an alle, die irgendwie kommerziell mit diesen Werken tätig werden wollen. Und zugleich wollen wir aber auch so neuere Entwicklungen im Netz, so Social Media Entwicklungen aufnehmen und halt auch freiwillige Zahlungen, also quasi diese Flettersysteme halt auch ermöglichen. Also dass es auch möglich ist, obwohl man keine Gebühren zahlen muss, den Leuten, die das gerne machen wollen, eine Möglichkeit zu geben, dass unkompliziert über eine neutrale Stelle, die nicht selbst noch Geld verdienen will, Verwertungsgesellschaften sind ja von Gesetz her daran gebunden, dass sie nicht selbst in eigenem wirtschaftlichen Interesse arbeiten, sondern wirklich nur treuhänderisch die Gelder weiterverwalten, dass über so einen Service international und zwar auch gleich europaweit zum Beispiel auch freiwillige Zahlungen gemacht werden kann.
Wie wollt ihr denn feststellen, wer wieviel kriegt? Wollt ihr dann irgendwie Downloads messen oder müssen dann die Leute dann auch wieder Listen ausfüllen wie bei der GEMA oder wie soll das laufen?
Die Leute, die tatsächlich kommerziell das verwenden wollen, die müssen dann logischerweise weiter Listen führen. Da sehen wir auch kein großes Datenschutzproblem. Ob jetzt dann in welchem Club welcher Titel gespielt wurde, das ist jetzt irgendwie nicht so das große Ding. Und bei den freiwilligen Zahlungen müssen wir gar nicht wissen, wer welche Musik wann gehört hat. Es geht halt nur darum, dass wir wissen, wer von seinem Etat welchem Künstler was geben will.
Okay, das wird dann einfach direkt auch angesagt mit der Zahlung. Habt ihr hier Maha und Herr Obach von diesem Projekt schon gehört?
Ja.
Geht das irgendwie zusammen oder ist das nochmal eine eigene Baustelle?
Ich hab davon schon mal gehört und ich halte das für sinnvoll. Einfach um weniger das Problem Filesharing in den Griff zu kriegen, aber einfach um den Gedanken der freien Lizenzen weiter voranzutreiben, was einfach unglaublich wichtig ist. Ich möchte, wenn ich zum Beispiel ein Musikstück veröffentliche, also diese Doppel-Lizenzierung eigentlich. Ich will es halt einmal für share-like, also einfach normal veröffentlichen, und einmal mit NC. Und es muss halt klar sein, wer macht hier gerade was und dass da nicht Leute an den Kragen gepisst bekommen, weil plötzlich irgendwas doch kommerziell sein soll, obwohl sie zu Hause eine Party gefeiert haben. Aber ich finde, das ist glaube ich ein wichtiger Aspekt, die Doppel-Lizenzierung. Ich kann ein Werk so auflizenzieren, wie ich möchte, in den verschiedensten Lizenzen. Da eben nicht, wenn du GEMA-Mitglied bist. Dann eben nicht mehr. Und das ist halt wirklich die Sache dahinter. Und ich halte das für total wichtig, gerade um den CC-Gedanken zu stärken und freie Kultur zu fördern.
So, Mike, wie gesagt, das geht ja schon irgendwie eineinhalb Jahre, zwei Jahre. Gibt es schon so einen Glaskugeltermin, wann es möglicherweise unter Umständen eventuell mal losgehen könnte?
Ja, wir haben ja jetzt die letzten Wochen auch ordentlich Presse gekriegt, nachdem wir das auf der Second nochmal gebracht haben und in diversen anderen Veranstaltungen, Future Music Camp und so weiter. Der Schlüsselpunkt ist jetzt im Augenblick im Wesentlichen das Repertoire, dass wir das zusammenkriegen. Das sieht aber gerade sehr gut aus. Man kann sie auf unserer Homepage auf so ein Newsletter eintragen und dann geht da auf jeden Fall auch die Meldung raus, wenn es wirklich ernst wird, sich zu melden mit Repertoire. So genau kann man das nicht sagen. Das Repertoire muss halt im Verhältnis zu den Verwaltungskosten insgesamt stehen. Das heißt, man kann theoretisch mit ein paar Künstlern das machen, wenn man halt quasi null Verwaltungskosten hat, weil dann irgendwie auch rein wirtschaftlich das Geld, was reinkommt, auch an die Künstler ausgezahlt werden kann.
Verstehe, verstehe. Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, großartiger Plan, aber ich beneide euch nicht, das scheint mir doch sehr komplex zu sein.
Das ist es auch, ja. Um noch eine Zeitmarke zu nennen, wir haben halt wirklich vor, zum Ende des Jahres tatsächlich die Lizenz beim Patentamt zu beantragen.
Okay, dann lass uns wissen, wann es soweit ist. Und vielen Dank erstmal für diesen Einblick. Alles klar. Das war Mike, Michalke. Und dazu wird es auch einen Link geben in den Sendungsnotizen.
Ich möchte noch ganz kurz zu GEMA sagen. Hätte mich vorhin gesagt, dass es kein Verein ist, es ist eine Stiftung. Und es ist eine per Erlass gegründete Stiftung. Es ist aber das gleiche Prinzip, als wenn es eine Behörde gibt, die hat einen Erlass, dass der GEMA ergründet werden soll. Das macht das im Ministerium. Und der Herr Bundespräsident muss zustimmen. Und dann gibt es diese Behörden. Oder diese Behörden ähnlichen Strukturen. Also es ist eine rechtsfähige öffentliche Stiftung des behördlichen Rechts.
Jetzt haben wir in den letzten fast zwei Stunden besprochen die beiden großen Dinge. Nämlich A, es gibt halt immer Gesetzgebung, die sehr hart wirkt und gegen die ihr protestieren wollt. Und andererseits gibt es so ein paar Ideen, wie man diese neue Situation, die im Internet jetzt gerade einfach mal herrscht, mit dem Tauschen von Dateien und Kunstwerken, auffängt und möglicherweise auch finanzierbar macht. Aus der Perspektive zu sagen von euch betrachtet, sieht das im Prinzip so aus gerade. Protest, Protest, Protest. Und nochmal Ideen entwickeln. Wie sieht denn das jetzt in näherer Zukunft aus? Also wenn ich jetzt mal zynisch pragmatisch denke, denke ich so, die Abmahnanmelde werden auch in den nächsten 5 Jahren noch ihr Geld verdienen. Was sind denn jetzt so?
Da müsste man glaube ich, da kann man glaube ich gegen vorgehen. Also das Massenabmahnend, dass das keine Perspektive hat, da sind sicher praktisch alle einig. Also da gibt es auch wieder ein ganz breites Bündnis über alle Parteien hinweg. Also das ist sicherlich auch, da kriegt man sogar die CDU und CSU ins Boot. Naja, die haben halt viele Juristen, die haben auch viele Leute, also viele Richter. So Richter und Professoren gelten ja immer sehr konservativ in Deutschland. Die möchten aber nicht dauernd mit diesem Abmahnzeug zu tun haben. Und von daher denke ich, werden wir das noch in den nächsten fünf Jahren erleben, dass es Maßnahmen gibt gegen Massenabmahn. Also ich denke, das wird wirklich verschwinden. Wir müssen dann aufpassen, dass nicht an die Stelle der Massenabmahnung dann irgendwie so ein Three-Strikes-Modell ist. Genau, das ist ja auch bestätigt worden. Das wäre natürlich schlimmer. Das wäre tatsächlich den Teufel mit dem Pelzebump verjagen. Aber ich fand es halt schon schön, dass sich die Justizministerin ganz klar gegen Massenabmahnung positioniert hat. Jetzt warten wir auf die Initiative aus dem Justizministerium, um das halt irgendwie gesetzlich in den Griff zu kriegen. Ansonsten war auch schön, dass Diskussionen über Tooth Strikes, also das Warnsystem der deutschen Musikwirtschaft und auch Three Strikes, die bisher immer kaputt gegangen sind und abgespittert worden sind. Also ich hoffe, dass wir auch da unsere Politik da, was das betrifft, standhaft bleibt und einfach erkennt, dass Internet mehr ist als nur ein bisschen rumklicken, sondern wirklich für Menschen Lebensraum.
Also wenn man euch hier so im Studio sieht, würde ich ja manchmal denken, das ist nicht der Fall.
Aber nur weil wir klicken können. Naja, wir müssen auch nochmal ganz klar da sagen, dieses Abmahnen, das bringt den Urhebern nichts. Mir ist ja vorgeworfen worden, ich sei gegen, wenn ich gegen Abmahn sei, sage ich auch gegen die Steuerfahndung. Das ist natürlich blödsinnig, weil die Steuerfahndung natürlich tatsächlich dafür sorgt, dass Steuern einkommen. Das Abmahn bringt aber nur den Abmahnanwälten etwas und nicht den den Urhebern.
Nein, nicht ganz. Auf Spiegel gibt es gerade ein schönes Interview zwischen Christoph Lau und Jan Dilä und der sagt da so, ja er hätte in seiner letzten Abrechnung entdeckt, da wäre ihm tatsächlich auch Geld zugutekommen.
Dann hat es aber in seinem Vertrag so drinne stehen, dass aus den Abmahnungen dann auch Gelder an ihn fließen. Aber das Gro bleibt beim Abmahnanwalt, dann geht ein Teil an das Label oder den Verwerter halt, der die Abmahnung hervorgerufen hat und der kann entscheiden, was er damit macht. Der kann es auch für sich behalten. Weil er mahnt ja die unrechtmäßige Verwertung ab. Und die Verwertungsrechte hat der Künstler im Regelfall mit seinem Vertrag an die jeweilige Verwertung abgetreten.
Wir kommen jetzt quasi im Kreis zum Anfang der Sendung zurück. Da ging es ja um ACTA, dieses Handelsabkommen, wo genau dieses Two-Strikes oder Three-Strikes irgendwie auch mal drin stand. Also von wegen, wenn du böse bist, dann mahne ich deinen Ted Provider ab und schalte dir irgendwann das Netz aus. Da soll jetzt am 9. Juni, also nächsten Samstag, ein Protestaktions- irgendwas-Ding stattfinden. Beginnt 12 Uhr an der Oberbaumbrücke, habe ich schon gelernt. Was passiert da noch?
Naja, wie gesagt, es gibt da verschiedene Aktionen. Erstmal ist dieser Aktionstag weltweit, also international. Man kann, also man muss nicht zur Oberbaumbrücke. Da wird es eh dann wahrscheinlich zu voll. Offenbar, zumindest. Und es gibt natürlich auch noch andere Aktionen. Also es wird nicht einfach nur eine Demo geben. Es wird andere Leute geben, die vielleicht an der Oberbaumbrücke mit dem Floß starten und so. Also es gibt, da soll ja eine ganz bunte, ganz bunter Aktionstag sein. Mit ganz unterschiedlichen Aktivitäten.
Und wo findet das in Deutschland sonst noch statt?
In allen großen Städten. In Frankfurt bin ich in Kontakt mit den Leuten, die das vorbereiten. Also das ist, wie ich sagte ja schon, am einfachsten ist wirklich mit einer freien Suchmaschine einfach mal zu gucken und dann findet man sofort für seine Stadt die Aktion. Wenn es noch keine gibt und man in einer etwas größeren Stadt wohnt, dann sollte man sich selber sofort wachen, aktivieren. Ansonsten gibt es irgendwie da so ein Wiki von Stop ACTA Protest Info, das auch irgendwie Informationen bereithält. Das ist ein offenes Wiki, kann sich jeder eintragen, nur wiki.stopacta-protest.info Da finden sich auch alle Infos zu den jeweiligen Demos und zwar weltweit. Wir haben für Deutschland, ich klicke jetzt mal auf Deutschland drauf, gucke mal.
Live-Internet im Radio?
Ja, unglaublich. Augsburg, Ahlen, Landkreis Aurich, Berlin, Braunschweig, Bremen, Bremerhaven, Chemnitz, Dresden, Essen, Frankfurt am Main, Freiburg, Kreiswald.
Die Nachfolgesendung beginnt um 12 Uhr. Gibt es ansonsten Club-Technisch, also Chaos Computer Club, Chaos Radio, gibt es da noch irgendwie so Termine jetzt hier in Berlin, die man an den Mann bringen könnte, jeden Donnerstag?
Ja, jeden Donnerstag, genau. Im Chaos Computer Club ab 17 Uhr ist da jeder willkommen und jede willkommen bis Mitternacht. Also offenes Chaos, der sogenannte Club Discordia, ihr findet da immer statt. Also da kann man natürlich auch hinkommen und sich aktivieren. Und ansonsten für die Hackerinnen und Hacker da draußen, die GPN ist nächste Woche ab Donnerstag in Karlsruhe. Die Gulasch Programmier-Nacht mit Vorträgen, Hacken, Zusammensetzen. Oder in Brandenburg, wir machen hier Radio für Brandenburg. Die hedonistische internationale hat ihr Camp in der Nähe von Wittstock, also an der Dosse.
Die hedonistische internationale, falls ihr gerade nicht wisst, was das ist, empfinde ich euch da.
CAE 185.
Genau, und dann mal nachzugucken, was sie so getrieben haben, das sind sehr lustige Leute. Das Chaosradio war es damit. Vielen Dank an Herr Obach und Herrn Maha, die hier im Studio waren und uns ACTA und Kulturwertmark und andere urheberrechtliche Dinge erklärt haben. Ich bedanke mich bei euch fürs Zuhören und auch Mitmachen. Das Ganze gibt es als Podcast demnächst auf friz.de und dann ein bisschen später auch auf chaosradio.de. Hier kommt jetzt Henrik Schröder mit einem Punk-Rock-Nightflight und wird euch Musik in die Ohren hauen, die sie möglicherweise zum Blut bringen. Ich bin damit raus, mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich kann nur noch eins sagen, macht immer schon eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.